I just started.
Oh my gosh, you guys are paying.
Whoa.
OK.
Let me fix the volume.
Hello, testing, testing.
Testing, testing.
Alright.
Guys, the audio...
Oh wait, there's more audio options!
There's more audio options.
Oh wait, there are now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice!
OK.
Why wasn't that on the menu?
Blah, blah.
That's so crazy.
The menu was like three options.
It was.
It honestly was.
Audio, yes, no.
And also, do you want to mute the main menu music?
You could still do that.
The main menu music was really loud.
You could still mute the main menu music.
By the way, for those who don't know, Naima and I are both very sick.
We are.
I'm going away from the sickies.
Ew, no!
Get away from me!
No, get away from me!
We're just dedicated to our work.
We're going to get photos of Spiderman!
I'm going to kiss you, man.
What is happening?
We just gave you my germs.
What is...
Wait, I can edit?
Oh shit.
I was going to say, let's edit it because I can't tell who's who.
Oh no, I can be this girl.
I know exactly who I want to be.
I know who I...
Here, I'll switch.
Ladies, ladies.
I'll switch.
Get me photos of Spiderman.
You look like a cop.
No.
I look like a cop.
You look like a fucking...
Those undercover cops, but they're definitely not undercover.
This one actually looks like, you know when people are like, look, it's Vi, but with Jinx's hair color.
Oh yeah.
The game, is it like laggy?
Not laggy, but like...
It's just unresponsive, which I kind of expected.
Oh, are we conspiracy theorists?
Oh, are we?
What is this?
I mean...
But it's real.
We're going to figure out who shot JFK.
Oh, I can hear a vague echo, do you hear that?
That looks like JFK right there.
I don't think so.
Oh, I do hear it.
We're going to figure it out.
Okay, you're echoing.
Oh, am I echoing?
Yeah, just mildly.
I think I know why.
Okay, it should be better now.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah.
Yeah, that's better.
Thank you!
Oh my god, it was um...
Wait, is that...
Oh my god, there's planes and everything.
Alright, we need...
Okay, wait, let me check this first.
I like the YouTube red circle.
Plane!
Do you see it?
The city lights.
Okay, guys, it looks like I'm lagging in and out because I'm tabbing out and in because I'm trying to find Snuffy.
Snuffy has yet to un-private her stream.
Snuffy...
Do you see her?
Wait, no, I do...
No, she's invisible, right?
I don't even see her.
I feel like Ron does that.
Oh, she's called Snum.
Snum?
Oh, she's called Snum?
I'll invite her.
Snum.
I was like, where is she?
Yeah, I don't know.
I typed S-N-U and I was like, oh, there she is.
And then, like, compulsively hit the F key and then she went.
And I was like, what?
Oh yeah, now she's invisible.
No!
I invited her anyway, maybe I had to let her come in.
Alright, we'll see.
Alright, let me get some cough drops.
Current session is Sloppy Sister Session.
Only take one per day.
Did you really name this the Sloppy Sister Session?
Yeah, I did.
Sloppy Station?
We are from...
We are reporters.
Yeah.
Alright, let's see.
I'll just up everybody.
My audio guy was like, does this game have individual volume sliders for people?
Oh, Snuffy says the game bluescreened her.
What?
That's a good start to the day.
Hey guys, join our Discord here.
Tell them that it bluescreened us.
Hey, you bluescreened us.
Yeah, you bluescreened...
No, actually, don't do that, don't do that.
I think that's, like, a hate rate.
I think that's, like, actually...
I thought you were just telling us, not your chats.
Yeah, no, don't do that, don't do that.
Okay, if you do not say that line, we'll send you.
Dreamer abuses her power.
What else we got in here?
Wait, there's a store here.
Okay, that means we gotta make big money.
We need a pro camera trap.
God, why is there always a flashlight and a pro flashlight?
It means the flashlight standard is gonna be fucking bad.
There's a window here, but it leads to the locker room.
Wait, is this just a higher budget version of that free game that came out after Lethal Company, where you went down into this creepy place and recorded things and then watched it back afterwards?
Content warning, content warning.
Content warning, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's what I thought, too.
It looked really, like...
Yeah, it reminds me of that.
I didn't play that.
Darwin Awards.
What's Darwin?
Returns to flirt with death for life.
Oh, multipliers, that's cool.
I'm ready to flirt with anything, alive or dead.
Oh my god, what the fuck is that?
Those are some of the monsters.
Oh, I think that's why it's weird, is...
The run is not hold shift, it's like tap.
Your run looks really stupid, look at the run.
Oh, so... okay.
Says you.
I think there's like stamina.
Wait, what are the other controls?
There's jump.
Oh, there's crouch.
What's crouch?
Oh, the crouch is so laggy.
I think... yeah, it's really laggy, yeah.
I think it's not... I think it's toggled, not like... hold down.
Yeah, it is, it's toggled.
Yeah.
Oh, look at it go.
Oh, the press.
Oh yeah.
Oh, wait, wait, these are equipment.
We only have ten pictures.
How do you use it?
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait a minute, get over here.
Okay.
Get over here.
No, no, no.
I'm here, I'm here.
Next to me, next to me.
Oh, next to you.
What's it look like?
It's beautiful.
Oh, you can do...
Oh, wow!
That's what I look like?
Oh my god!
I look like an actual...
I'm sorry, I'm giving Snuffy tech support.
Oh, okay.
Apparently, she bluescreened and now it like crashes every time she boots.
Oh, what?
The game like killed her, so I'm giving my tech support.
This game?
Alright, guys, here are some pro tips when taking photos.
The higher the angle, the more flattering you look, guys, right here.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, guys, welcome back to my channel.
Hey,
guys, welcome back to my channel.
Today, we're going to be going on some epic, crazy adventures.
My name is PD, Peter Peterson.
This is a private session.
This is a collab.
This is a collab party.
What do you mean?
I don't collab with other YouTubers.
Oh, you're solo?
You're flying solo?
Yeah.
Today, we're going to do a crazy challenge.
See if I can get a monster to do 20 squats or every squat it does, I'll lose $10,000.
Okay, guys.
Remember to hit that like button.
Yeah, subscribe, subscribe, subscribe.
And get that notification.
Oh, the bell, the bell, the bell.
Ding-dong, ding-dong.
Go jump around while you're in selfie mode.
How am I holding the camera?
I'm just that good.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Doki Bird.
And today, we're going to go see some monsters today.
Oh, I see one right in front of me.
Whoa, me too.
Oh, my God.
Say cheese.
Oh, there she is.
Right here is what we call...
She's outside her natural habitat right now.
Whoa.
Said, I got this, then immediately regrets it.
These are the last known photos of our journalist.
Wait, are these actual people?
Wait, these are actual ads.
These are actual photos?
Oh, my God, it is.
Oh, my God, we need to be in this.
Look, this one has them kissing in front of the monster.
Oh, my God.
Wow, Johnny Boy.
Oh, my God, Johnny Boy.
Johnny Boy got some at the end.
Yeah, that could be you, everybody.
The last photo before she died.
These are awesome.
How did he die here?
How did Captain Peter die?
I don't think he died.
I think he's just...
These are all, like, last photos before they died, though.
Oh.
I like this guy's photo here.
This one's good.
He looks so, like, unafraid.
He's ready... He's facing death and he's facing it head on.
With his back.
I think this one is funny, too.
This one...
Like, you know someone else took that photo right here?
Yeah.
He's like, he's not behind us, right?
Wow, is this, like, a spoiler of things?
Oh, my gosh, there's a giant lady.
Wait!
Wait, Prissy!
Wait?
What am I doing?
Get in the camera!
Yeah, buddy!
Yeah, let's go!
Press 7!
7?
Oh, that's me!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, yeah, that's me!
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, it's like... Oh, wait, what number was that?
What number did you press?
6.
Hey there, buddy.
Wait, wait, do it live.
Do it live.
No, no, no, no.
Your other hand is going up.
What's the other... What's... I think it's 6, right?
This one?
Oh, no, the wrong way.
You gotta be on the other side.
Okay.
Nope.
Doki is a perpetual hover hander.
No, Riz!
I'm really scared.
Oh, my God.
I'm so close to another woman.
You get points for, like, doing emotes.
In the picture.
Oh, yeah.
What's number 5 for me?
If I download this, is it gonna expose my computer?
Yeah, it's pointing.
Okay, downloaded to desktop folder.
Cool.
She's downloading the photos from the game.
Am I doing... What am I doing?
You could actually download the footage.
Am I doing Gognum's...
Gognum's style.
Like this, like this.
Yeah.
What the... What the hell?
We need a chair.
We need a chair for this.
You're, like, opposite of it.
You're looking at the chair.
You're not sitting in the chair.
Oh, it's like sitting backwards in a chair.
Except it doesn't actually work.
I thought it was Gognum's style.
What's number 2?
You're jiving.
It looks like we're doing the twist.
Let's do the twist.
Hello, I'm Paul.
Hello.
Is that your name?
Hi, I'm Paul.
Hey, Paul.
Hey, everybody.
What's...
What's this one?
Is there one for 9?
She's, like, trying to...
Kill the resolution and stuff on it right now.
I'm going to go and investigate and see how it's going for her if she's live.
Okay.
How would she still be live if she blue screened?
Well, she's not blue screened right now.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
Should we put it back?
Drop.
I know.
I'm excited for that one.
Can we, like...
Get that.
If we're getting spoilers for the things we're going to see, but...
We could go right now.
Nah, we'll wait.
Snap great pictures, then get the F out.
Wait, they put too many...
They put too many stars.
Get the F-U-C-K.
No, F-U-C-K.
Yeah, there's another one.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's the freak out.
Yeah.
Get the freak out.
Oh, no.
Does your thing start lagging when you start running?
Like it starts going...
Like the camera.
No, it's fine for me.
I mean, I might have the tankier PC.
Said the one...
Said the person who needed to get replaced.
Yeah, but now it's okay.
It crashed like two days ago, but now it's okay.
Okay.
Oh, we have no money.
We can get a trap.
We can get a big backpack.
Okay.
What are you going to do with a helmet?
Are they like...
What are you going to throw rocks at me?
Like...
Are they going to throw rocks at us?
They could.
Or bullets.
I mean, it doesn't look too dangerous.
No, it looks so clean.
Wait, is that...
Yeah.
It's like a...
There's like shooting stars.
In the night sky.
Shooting stars.
I can't believe it.
No.
I don't think...
They're not bullets, right?
No, right?
No.
That's not gunfire.
I do hear an ambulance.
I mean, to be fair, there is no one walking outside.
But it's like...
You know, after a curfew.
Ever since the government instated a nationwide curfew.
You know, this is how it's going to look like now.
I think it's a nice warm ambiance.
I like it.
It's kind of smoggy.
It's like, you know...
It's just New York City.
Yeah.
Regular New York City night.
Wasn't...
Wasn't like New York City like red at one point?
Because of like the fires?
Yeah, actually.
That's actually what I was thinking of.
I was like, damn, this kind of reminds me of that.
Oh no, we threw away the newspaper.
We're failures at journalism.
Nobody wants to read our paper.
No, it's because we're starting our career now.
We're going to make it big.
We're going to get the front page news, guys.
Oh yeah, front page news.
Because I decided to go into journalism in 2025.
Oh, why does my thing do that when I run?
Why does it do this?
Oh my God.
Nuffy is still having problems.
I'm trying to help fix it.
No!
What's going on?
It might be...
You know the whole thing where Intel CPUs are...
We're like getting really unstable.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, she stopped Intel?
I'm like...
Yeah, I'm kind of like scanning her chat.
And it's like, oh, oh no.
Oh no.
I think it might be like the degraded CPU thingy.
No.
Oh, she might need to turn it like...
Yeah.
To play headliners?
That's crazy.
Yeah, the headliner is too powerful.
Oh no.
The only time I've ever had to underclock my PC was for Marvel Rivals.
That's crazy.
Why is it so...
Marvel Rivals runs so weird.
Like, no matter what I change, it runs at basically the same frame rate.
Yeah, it's just incredibly tanky in general.
Yeah.
Woo!
Is there batteries?
Oh, there's batteries for flashlight, by the way.
I put my phone away.
I mean, my camera away.
Your phone away?
My camera.
Oh, I see it, I see it.
Wait, I wonder if I could take your phone.
Now you're calling it a phone.
Oh, I can!
If I could take your camera, I could take your... Like, I could see your photos.
Wait, do you see it?
Wait, let me see.
Yeah, yeah.
Why is Snuffy Leclerc in this photo?
Head bobbing.
Maybe it's that.
OK, let me try it.
Oh, there's head bobbing?
Apparently.
I think maybe that's what's...
Bless you!
Oh, bless you!
Where's the head bobbing part?
I don't see it.
I don't know, that's what somebody told me.
There's no head bobbing.
I think I got one guide.
I got one guide.
You got one guide.
Yeah, maybe.
Glitch or network lag.
That might be it, I think.
Because everything else is running fine.
Hey there, lady.
Maybe I should have hosted because I'm the most central.
Yeah, you didn't host, everyone.
That's not a bad idea.
Honestly, yeah, why am I hosting?
I'm West Coast.
Yeah, you want me to host?
We have plenty of time to switch it up while Snuffy tries to figure this out, so if I would switch it up...
OK, OK.
Get out of my room right now.
OK.
Goodbye, everybody.
Thanks for the stream.
This was a lot of fun.
Yeah, everyone.
That was so fun.
Bye, guys.
Alright, guys.
Anyway, I didn't get to say hello.
Welcome to the headliners.
We'll be playing with Doki, Snuffy, hopefully, and Limu.
I'm kind of worried for Snuffy's computer.
This is exactly why I switched from Intel.
OK, so I play and then I...
Oh, let me hide.
Hold on.
Let me make sure that...
Actually, let me change one other thing.
You know what?
I am gonna go.
I don't see anything about...
Head bobbing.
OK, play, create session just in case so that you guys can't see.
Oh, friends only.
Just kidding.
You guys can see now.
Session name.
Snuffy sisters.
Welcome back.
Got some jobs for you.
OK, let me tell them that I made it.
Oh, gosh.
Poor Snuffy.
No.
Thank you guys for all the superchats and the donos and the gifteds too.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry, it's hard to say.
In collab.
Want to join from me.
Oh, wait.
Can they join from me?
Hello.
Oh, you have like three lives too.
What is?
I have three what?
You have three lives.
That's like the little passes, right?
Yeah, I think that's what the passes are, yeah.
Or press pass.
Oh, my God.
Oh, this is already looking so much better.
Oh, it must have been the ping then.
Maybe.
I'm fine though.
On your server.
Okay.
I don't know what it was.
Maybe it was like...
Also with Limu connecting.
I don't know.
Maybe.
I don't know actually.
Hello.
Because like for me...
Apparently, VTube Studio... What the fuck?
Press, press, press.
What?
I've got like the press badges showing up.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think those are lives.
Yeah, that's why I thought earlier the game was starting.
I was like, oh, my God.
Yeah.
So apparently, it was VTube Studio.
Oh, it was VTube Studios?
I think it was like...
I think it's like her CPU is dying so hard that having both running kind of broke everything.
Oh, my God.
So today was the day she found out her PC is dying.
That's...
I think they already did the thing where they under-vaulted it.
It's just not enough anymore or something.
I don't know.
No, if you under-vaulted... If you under-clock your PC too much, you start breaking your PC.
Yeah.
So, like, I think she just needs to get a new PC at this point.
I mean, the PC...
Well, I think the X-Series comes out.
That'd be sad.
Rest in peace.
Bye.
What was that?
And she got a blue screen.
And her CPU... No, her PC died trying to play Headliners and her CPU fried.
Lyrical genius!
Wait, Lime, do you want to change back to your old outfit?
Oh, right, right, right.
Hold on a second.
The way you run is so funny.
Because I have green hair.
Yeah.
Don't be the token woman in the group.
I know.
Actually, oh, I'm gonna be this guy.
You're bald.
That's it?
He's like, mhm.
Don't I look like I belong in New York?
Like, I look like Seinfeld.
You look like...
Well, the one thing that's missing is that Seinfeld has a head of hair.
No, his friend.
George.
George Costanza.
Yeah, but he doesn't have glasses.
I've never watched Seinfeld, by the way.
I don't know who George is.
I just know Seinfeld.
Oh my god, I've watched all of Seinfeld.
Damn, what a hag.
I literally watched it like two years ago.
Don't even.
Two years ago.
Is it because you watched the Seinfeld AI shit?
Is that why?
No, I watched Seinfeld before the AI.
And then I watched the AI and was like, whoa, this is so accurate.
Nothing's happening.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two years ago.
What's the deal with VTubers?
What's the deal with Snuffy's computer?
I think we've gotten there.
She switched models to a less intensive one on VTube Studio and it might not be alright.
I feel so bad for her.
It's so frustrating when your computer's not working the way it should.
Yeah, I can't believe Death by Headliners.
What a way to go.
Death by Kuso game.
Of all the things to take you out, right?
Of all the things, it has to be a Kuso game.
Oh my god, you found a music player.
Holy shit.
That's right.
Wait, how do you dance again?
It's two.
Two.
I actually have this whole thing with Path of Exile 2 where that thing will, like, break my computer.
And that sucks.
Nice dancing.
What is your mouth doing when you dance?
Holy shit.
What's your mouth doing?
Oh no.
I keep dancing.
Okay, look at the photo.
Look at the photo.
I'm looking.
I look like I'm creeping on her.
Look at him go.
No!
Hold on, here you go.
Here you go.
Live, if you want to see the picture.
Yeah, I do.
Out of a gallery.
Oh man, freaky.
There you go.
Man, what a freak.
That's what they call me at the club.
At the club.
Let's go.
Whose jacket?
Whose scarf?
Whoa, whose scarf is that?
Wait, I wonder if there's new photos.
I'm gonna check.
Oh yeah, see if they've changed.
No, they're the same ones.
Maybe it's just, like, a standard set then.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe it's, like, submitted.
Like, Twitter users submit it and then they change it every so often.
We gotta get on here.
Alright, we gotta get some good photos in.
Yeah, and if we post these, you guys gotta like it so that they notice.
Yeah, yeah, so the devs will add us into the photos.
Yeah.
I wonder if you can change the channels.
Oh, there was a different one earlier.
Maybe...
Oh, see?
Stop laughing at me!
Is it Girls Just Wanna Have Fun?
It really is Walmart Girls Just Wanna Have Fun.
The phone rings in the middle of the night.
My mayor of the town said, I'm fighting for my life.
I need someone to take a picture of the kaiju.
The press just wanna have fun.
Oh, the press just wanna have fun.
Apparently, taking my invite to this session caused OBS to crash.
No!
It's the whole thing that's so cursed for her.
This is so cursed.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, no, that's the wrong one.
Which one was it?
Oh, god damn it.
It's one, it's one, it's one.
Oh, it's one?
Okay.
Is it working?
No.
Wait, hold on.
Let me see this.
Does it... Wait.
Which one is it?
Which one is the hover hand?
No.
Oh, it's six, I think.
Six?
Yeah, yeah, six.
Does it look like I'm cool against the wall?
It does, actually.
I think that's what it's supposed to be, rather than putting your arm around someone.
Snub joined!
Snub!
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, my god!
Snuffy!
Hello?
Hi, you're here!
You're with us!
Oh, my god, it's using the good... Okay, wait, hold on.
We missed you.
I feel... This is wrong.
Are you okay?
What did you have to do to get it working?
What did you do?
Naked!
I'm completely naked!
I'm like a flesh streamer!
I'm nothing!
It's just the game!
I can't play with any sort of, like, VTube studio!
I'm like...
Where's my... Where's my beautiful face and, like, quirky traits?
You can, like, put your own foogie on the reactive thing on the bottom, so at least you can include yourself there.
Oh, yeah, true.
Now that it finally works.
You have to be a YouTuber.
I'm too afraid!
Anything else, like, if I tap it, it's like...
If you tap out, it'll probably break everything.
It's like Jenga!
If I move one thing, it's gonna shatter!
You know what's gonna happen?
We're all gonna be, like, super excited.
It's gonna finally be working.
We go into the mission, and you instantly crash.
I'm calling it now.
I'm calling it.
No, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
I believe!
I'm a believer!
I'm, like, super, super sorry for, like, all of that.
You're fine.
No!
I did not expect for it to, like, crash.
It's okay!
Look at us dance!
I'm patting your head.
We figured out how to dance, and then we found the copy of Girls Just Wanna Have Fun At Home.
So we're having a really good time.
So there's emotes.
You know, number keys are emotes, by the way.
Yeah, one through eight.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Let me get my CD up really quick.
Also, there's a girl with blue hair that you can be if you want over here.
Oh, I thought you guys just made your characters.
No, no.
You can introduce yourself over here.
You think I would've made this?
Yes!
So that was my first pick, was that was instantly, you made that.
Thank you!
Wait, wait, wait.
Lean against the wall so I can take that picture.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, uh...
It should be the brick wall, the brick wall.
Yeah, brick wall.
That's where the aesthetic is.
Check me out, check me out.
I'm, like, wistfully looking out the window.
Uh, tonight, we're gonna be catching some real monsters.
Wait, don't talk, don't talk when you do it.
Okay.
Did you get it?
I get it.
Your expression.
He's just a chill guy.
This looks like a real...
With a smile.
Oh!
Look at this photo.
That took a minute.
It looks too...
It looks too chill.
I can't...
Oh, I gotta drop my camera.
Oh, wait, no, that's my flash.
I'll just drop everything, whatever.
What do you got in there?
Nothing.
Okay.
How the fuck do I...
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
My camera has all the real photos.
We can actually toggle music by doing this.
Yeah.
That's all the real photos.
Mm.
Oh, yeah, I like that one.
I learned it.
Okay, I think I'm good now.
What did we learn?
Teach me.
We've learned...
Over here are the lockers if you wanna change your appearance.
You wanna change your appearance?
Yeah, we learned about...
Whoa, whoa.
Locker.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, oh.
I like your girl hair.
Thank you.
I like yours as well.
I think that's the best one we gotta remember.
I'm just basically like, screw the rules.
I have green hair.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For the photos.
All right.
Woo!
All right, you guys all ready?
Oh, yeah.
Step in, Snuffy.
Go get your camera.
Yeah, we gotta get it.
Oh, okay.
Did you ever play Content Warning, Snuffy?
Because I feel like this is, like, just modern...
Or, you know, day...
Modern.
This setting is...
Yeah, modern.
Day-to-day content warning.
Or, no, no.
Cloverfield content warning.
That's what it is.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's Cloverfield content warning.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, that looks like...
This really looks like Cloverfield.
It's a movie where, like, a big old Godzilla-type thing invades New York.
Snuffy, Snuffy, this looks like...
Yeah.
This is basically Cloverfield.
Yeah, it was, like...
Yeah, no, it is.
That's Cloverfield.
Wait, the guy's car or the thing?
The monster.
No, the monster.
The monster is Cloverfield.
It had, like, crazy ARG marketing when it first came out.
It was...
What was the name of the drink that was, like, responsible?
Like, there was a drinks company, and they were drilling for the secret ingredient for the drink, and that's how they discovered the monster.
What?
The Cloverfield had a drink.
I swear to God.
Oh, Slusho.
Slusho.
Yeah, Slusho drinks.
Chat, we're in the natural habitat of hags right now, I think.
As we discuss our favorite movie.
And ARGs.
Fuck you.
It was cool.
Yeah, let's go get some pictures.
Green doors equals get in.
Okay.
Oh, Pequod!
The Slusho ARG.
I just don't like that voice.
It fucking hurts.
No!
I'm gonna shine a fucking flashlight in your face the whole time.
I swear to God.
Okay.
You guys were alive during the ARG of Cloverfield?
Right?
Who's flying?
Pequod.
Oh, where is she?
I found the anomaly.
What do we do?
Hello?
No!
Somebody can't hear me.
I can hear you, I can hear you.
That sucks.
I knew it would happen.
We literally looked at each other and I was like, is Snoopy still here?
And then there were only three people in the helicopter.
I was like...
Oh, Snoopy!
I'm so sorry.
I should've like triple-double-extra checked that this was an unplayable game for me.
You wouldn't have thought.
This game looks so casual.
Yeah, it really does.
I've never had a game give me as much trouble as this has.
It's because you're a raccoon.
So Marvel Rivals has hurt us all, I see.
Wait, it shows you're still in the game though.
That's weird.
Can you join mid-session?
Yeah, I'll try that.
Why the hell not?
Hell yeah.
Yeah, it shows current session, your name's in there.
Snub!
I see you, Snub!
No, Snub!
Where are you, Snub?
Okay, so I tried to join.
It took me to the homepage.
The first lobby is Midwest Marijuana Enthusiasts.
Yeah, obviously that is us.
Maybe you invite her back in.
I've been inviting her.
Okay, okay, let me see.
Maybe it manually kicks her or something.
Okay, yeah, let me kick you.
Joining from Limu's invite.
No, it crashes.
Out of memory.
It doesn't let me kick you, you're stuck in the game.
You've been Sword Art Online'd into headliners.
I'm stealing your identity, Mint, and I'm fucking haunting this collab.
Oh, I see Snub there.
So the options, I guess, are either you bow out, which will make us very sad, or you stop streaming and you play with us and see if it doesn't crash.
I guess those are the options.
There's people crying outside, Gus.
What do you mean people crying?
If OBS was running, it would still boot up.
This is a persistent issue I've had with my Intel for a while, so I think it's just my computer is at its peak right now.
Do I need to start a GoFundMe for you to switch to AMD?
I've been working with Ironside, because they're the ones who made this computer, and I've been trying to have them help me fix it, but they need me to flash BIOS and basically restart the entire PC.
It's just been a long process of, like, I also need to stream.
That's so frustrating.
I'm sorry, Snobby.
No, that's okay.
I am so sorry, you guys.
If you want to do it, you guys should live it up.
I hope you have a great game and everything.
I'm super sorry.
We'll play this again together when we're all four again.
Your head keeps twisting.
Yeah, you keep doing this.
You know, we did bring you guys on the next one.
Look at Snobby, they can do some Bond Hunters.
Yeah!
Back into the fray.
Bye, Snobby!
Okay, I'm gonna go back into the game.
Why on earth can we 360 our heads?
Alright, we also have a time limit.
We have six minutes left.
We have six minutes to capture footage.
Guys, there was a lot of sounds around me.
I'm really scared.
There was a guy in his underwear that ran past us at the very start.
I didn't want to disrupt the heartfelt conversation with Snobby, but he fucking sprinted past us in his undies.
Yo, maybe that was the monster.
Oh, I hear something.
Where?
No, I don't think we gotta take a picture.
Hello, survivor.
You have a witness account?
She's not interested in your shit.
Did she just scream at me?
What did you see over there?
What did you see?
Please, please.
Hey, hey sir.
Sir, can I get just one sentence?
How do you feel about this whole situation?
Did you have monster insurance on your car?
What was that?
Oh yeah!
What?
Oh my god.
Pose in front of him.
Here, I'll pose in front.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Hey buddy.
Oh, I was still alive!
I didn't think I was still alive after that.
I hope they got a good picture.
Dude, she's in fucking pieces on the floor.
Go down there, you coward!
Get closer, Doki!
Get closer.
What is this?
Wait, get my camera!
Oh, that's me.
I should have selfied in front of him.
Aw man.
She got absolutely murdered in 0.2 seconds.
Get the camera, get my camera!
There's another dog monster.
Oh, there's a dude in his underwear.
There he is!
There's a stripper.
Ok, we need to get her camera because she had photos too.
What the hell was that?
Why is there a leg flying?
I threw that.
Oh damn, she's taking my body.
I got the real deal.
The guy with his underwear is just running around by the cars now.
Wait, wait, we need to take a picture of that.
He's below us.
Here he is.
Ok.
She just knocked that car over.
She's got superhuman strength.
Streaking at this hour.
This is the best time to streak.
If it's the apocalypse, I'd streak too.
Scared?
Go to the dog.
How do we get out of here?
I think we just go back to the helicopter.
You know what, I feel like we did a good job.
What?
Yeah, I got some cool pictures.
And she's like here with us.
Do you think we get a reward for bringing back her torso?
Probably.
Oh my god, there I am.
Let's go.
Everyone's here.
Ok.
I only have three...
I still have three press cards.
Hello,
I'm back.
I told you.
We made it.
We can rebuild here.
We're checking the results on the TV.
Check the results.
Let's see.
Results.
Here we go.
Yeah, that's me.
Why is it just me?
I got every good photo.
Where am I?
I was just used for your content.
What do you mean?
There you are.
I literally see you.
You're right.
Very good.
Good job, everybody.
It's too good.
I'm downloading my favorite photos.
Did we just take the top photo, I guess?
From everything, which would be this one.
Oh no, we can just look at them.
Yeah, you just look at them.
Dog alien and then you dying.
You get money for blood.
We can buy more stuff now, like a pro camera so we can take more photos.
You can do that, I have no money.
Ma 'am, what are you doing?
And there's me dancing next to your body part.
We need to convert the points into photos.
I'm sorry, into money, which I guess we can only do at the end.
Okay, so we have two more press badges, so we can do this two more times.
Got you.
So we need to reach 1500 by...
Okay, got you.
Makes sense.
Green doors equal get in.
Ma'am, why didn't you emote next to the dog?
We could have gotten more points.
He came at me!
I'm sorry!
He came at me and then I was just like...
Oh, I'm dead.
I don't even think you have a degree in journalism.
Well, then he attacked me again, so he can get you twice, I think.
Wait, how do we get the plane to start?
I think it won't because Snuffy is still technically in the...
Oh no, she's gone.
Okay.
Hey!
Oh, I need to equip a camera.
Oh, you have a camera.
It's you.
Wait, there's no cameras here.
Oh.
How do you...
You have to buy a camera.
I don't have any money!
Oh, it's free.
I don't get my flashlight back, though.
Thanks for grabbing that instead of, you know...
my body.
Oh, that's the thanks I get after rebuilding you?
Alright, I see.
I literally rebuilt you from nothing.
From just a torso.
Okay, let's go!
We're off to see...
Everything in the city!
Yeah!
Danger level one?
Oh my gosh, this is gonna be a piece of cake.
I died on a danger level one.
No, that was probably a danger level like...
What?!
I got you all those photos because I went in!
I went in and got those photos for you!
Oh, money is shared, by the way.
What are we looking for?
Is he still there?
No, there's no dog.
Dog creature is not here this time.
Alright, YOLO, let's go in.
Then we're free to go down.
Oh, you're going this way?
Okay.
Gotta find something exciting!
That's a beautiful door!
Green doors mean we can go in!
Green doors!
Let's go in.
It's that blue light over there.
Hold on.
What is that?
I hear something.
Green doors, go in!
Green doors, go in.
I'm opening.
Oh.
Hello?
Hi!
Okay.
There's a little...
What was that?
Look at the ground!
Hello?
What was that?
Did you not see the thing running towards us?
There was a little...
No!
There was a little thing that ran towards us!
Everybody saw it!
Are you sure?
Alright, let's go in then.
I'm in.
There's pizza!
Possibly.
Do you see that?
The ghostly essence?
Yeah.
What the hell was that?
Did you see that?
Are you hiding?
Wait, can we all be in here?
Hello?
Someone is going to get fucking eaten.
Okay, we're good.
I have a feeling this stalker isn't good.
Yeah, I feel like he's going to come back.
No, I'm fine in here.
Be brave then!
I got a picture of him!
Hold on, I'm going to emote on him.
Is he coming back?
I don't know.
He's not here.
Alright, come on Doki!
Be brave!
Alright, I got it.
I'm going to go by myself.
We're going.
What the hell?
What just happened?
He's a hiding survivor.
Let's go follow him.
Why is this game so scary?
Because it's a horror game.
Oh, hey buddy.
What do you have to say?
Can you move?
He's actually blocking us from moving.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Oh, there we go.
Who is this?
He's a hiding survivor.
He's here to hide.
Every time I talk in game discord, I can see on my second monitor.
It's like, you're currently muted.
Oh, I hate that.
Oh my god, look at him, look at him.
Oh, look, look, look!
Doki, there's like a trap here.
Oh, shit!
It's a constant warning trap!
Yeah!
You don't have good photos, right?
Hold on.
Wow, look at this mom!
What the hell?
Is this guy actually following us?
What do you want?
I mean, he's probably shit scared.
We should trick him into the trap so we can take a picture of him eating.
Oh, true, true, true.
Poor awful people.
Hey, hey!
I think he's fixated on you.
Hey, kid, come on.
Let's go somewhere safe.
Over here.
Oh, here he comes, here he comes!
Get your cameras ready!
Come on, come on!
Yeah!
Good job!
It's going all Technicolor outside.
That's probably bad.
Technicolor?
It kind of went all purple out there.
It's just acid rain.
Oh, no, it's the lighting system in here.
Okay, we're fine.
I think we should go back.
We have a lot of good photos now, right?
Oh, I see it, I see it.
What is it?
It's in the other room.
I saw red eyes running around.
Oh, it's a soccer.
Wait, how did we get back?
I don't remember where we came from.
Uh, this way.
Up the stairs?
We're actually leaving?
I think so.
No, it's not up the stairs.
I don't think so.
It was through here.
Oh, I can't see anything.
Wait, I don't have a...
Here, here, here.
I got you.
Oh, yeah, it was here, because there's the locker.
And that's where the photo is.
Yeah, and it's straight through here.
I think we should go back.
I think we have all the photos we need.
I still have six photos I can take.
I'm about halfway through mine, so it depends on whether or not we want to risk dying.
I have two.
Yeah, I don't want to risk dying.
We have some sick-ass photos.
There might be some shit in the square as well.
Oh, okay, okay.
Alright, let's get these first.
Team safe.
There's no dogs here.
Oh, yes, there's something in the square.
Oh, there's two dogs.
Is that a not-dog?
That's three enemies right there.
Can you zoom?
Look at them go.
Wait, is this like...
Is this like Lethal Company, where the longer you're out, the more things spawn?
I think this is RNG, I'm pretty sure.
Oh god, can you actually make that?
How to tell?
I can't get up there.
Guys, don't come over here, you'll get stuck, JK.
Oh, okay.
Well, what do we do?
Oh, just crouch jump it, Mint.
Oh.
It's just kind of finicky because it's laggy.
How do you crouch jump?
Jump and then hit control as you're in the air.
It lifts your legs up.
Yeah, but then how am I stuck here?
Oh, it might just be fiddly.
I think Toki might be dying also.
Oh, yeah, no, they're chasing her.
Great, great, great.
Take a photo, take a photo.
I don't like that sound.
Hey, what's up?
I'm coming.
I'm making my way.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
There's a monster below us.
To our right.
What is it?
So we gotta book it, we gotta book it.
He's like right to the right.
Okay, where?
I should've taken a picture of the guy.
Where?
We're gonna go.
Alright, three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
I'm booking him, I'm running as fast as I can.
Did you send her down there to die?
Nah, she made it.
Where is it?
I don't even know what she's seeing.
I don't see what she saw.
Yeah, she's hallucinating for real.
We only have two minutes.
What the?
What was that?
Oh, I see him.
Do you see him by the post there?
Oh yeah!
He's coming back.
Uh-oh.
Doki says, guys, there's a monster right in front of me.
That sounds bad.
I can hear her shouting for help.
Should we stop ignoring her maybe?
I don't know if we'll make it.
Oh, he just left.
Okay, I think we can go.
I can hear her screaming.
We should get into the helicopter.
Go, go, go!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Oh my God, he's right there.
Turn around, turn around, take a photo, take a photo of him!
Turn around, take a photo!
He's far away!
Yeah!
I could just hear you in the distance like, guys...
This is not a game for Doki.
She's too much of a coward.
This is not a game for you, Doki.
Yeah, I was getting photos.
I was taking photos, what are you talking about?
I got a great photo while you were running.
I'm gonna have the best photo today.
Number one!
Wait, what the hell is that?
Oh no, that's number five!
He was in front of me as I was taking a photo, it was really funny.
Number four!
Number three!
Yes, my photo!
Number two!
What is that?
Why did I get a single one?
Get in the locker!
That's right.
That's right, it was me.
Objective complete.
I even baited that guy into the trap.
Wait, you didn't get a single photo at all?
What?
We can afford exactly one thing.
Do you want a pro camera?
Or do you want...
Maybe a helmet?
What is a helmet for?
I guess we can give a helmet to Mint.
And then use her as bait warrior.
Hold on, it's plus 25% health.
Then the trap will block monsters.
We can buy Mint a flashlight.
Give me one.
Yeah, you have a flashlight, it's okay.
There's a zoom camera too.
For Doki, because she doesn't like to get close to anything.
True, but there's also a camera that lets you take 15 pictures.
I got the best photo in that game.
And I was very close to you guys.
Do you want the 15 pictures camera?
Or the zoom camera?
Or the flash camera?
I feel like the zoom camera would be better, right?
Oh...
You get less score for it.
Or the flashy camera?
Might be good, because we don't have to rely on the flashlight.
True, true.
The pro camera has the best pictures.
For what it's worth, so you get more score.
So we should get the pro camera then.
I think they add the pro camera then, so we can get more money.
Added to your stock, apparently.
I'll use the bathroom.
Do you want the pro camera?
No, you can have it.
You're gonna get the best shot of all of us now.
That's the plan.
You guys are so close to me right now.
Do you want the pro camera?
While basically licking my nose?
You want the pro camera?
I really like your eyeliner.
How it goes around your pores.
It goes around your whole eyes.
I haven't had the use of both of my nostrils since, I don't know, Friday.
You're like the color of your hair for real.
We're not the sloppy sisters today.
You guys are the snotty sisters.
It's true, it's true.
Welcome back.
Did you wash your hands?
Yeah, I did.
Who has it?
Mint has it because Mint has clearly got a great track record for taking good pictures.
Let's see again.
I'm sorry, this is the front line news?
I'm sorry, this is the front news?
What is this photo?
There's nothing in there!
It looks like you're in a compromising picture with that fucking monster, if I'm gonna be honest.
Breaking news, I've uncovered a secret relationship.
Oh wait, the monster is in that picture, I see him barely.
Yeah, he's literally right there next to you.
I am in a really compromising...
I have a scandal right there.
Extra, extra, read all about it.
Mint got all of her pants down.
It's not a scandal if I welcome it.
Oh yeah, I had relations with that monster and I'd have them again.
Let's go!
Do you think we'll get the scarier map now because we completed it?
Oh yeah, probably.
We have a higher thing now too.
Yeah, all we have in the world is a hundred dollars.
Mint's definitely not gonna die with the pro camera.
We have to sacrifice ourselves.
I won't die with the pro camera.
Oh, it's two now!
Bless you!
I didn't know if that would come through on the loading screen.
Alright, team.
What are we looking for?
Don't die.
Who are you saying that to?
Mint or me?
I'll try...
Mostly Mint, but also you because I care.
But if I get a great photo in death, isn't that the best thing?
If you get a great photo in death, we have to get your camera back.
Yeah, take the camera, take the camera.
Look, look, look!
There's another way up to the rooftops here.
Oh my god, your legs!
My eyes are up here.
Ladder, ladder, ladder.
You gotta say ladder, ladder, ladder when you climb, it's the rule.
Oh, the buildings are collapsing.
Oh, do we have to parkour here?
Oh god.
I'm gonna do it.
Parkour!
Made it.
Watch this.
Parkour.
We're the best journalists ever?
Wow.
Oh, there's a ladder over here too, so...
Oh, there's a light!
There's a green light!
Maybe there's doors below us.
Can we... Is there damage?
Fall damage?
Yeah, do a flip.
Do a flip, Mint.
How do you safely use these fucking ladders?
Mint, how do I go down the ladder?
You just press down!
I'm kinda stuck on the ladder.
No, you're not.
This is very dangerous.
Holy shit.
I'm taking your flashlight, Doki.
Thank you.
I'll miss her.
I won't.
Do you wanna go into the deli and grocery or whatever this building is?
Yeah, I was gonna say there's a second one.
Yeah, let's go into the grocery.
Ooh, that dog sounds real close.
Okay, let's go.
Okay, you have the pro camera, so if it gets dark, I will light the scene up for you.
Alright.
That elevator is smoking.
Yeah?
Yeah, it is.
There's also a room here.
Was that you opening it?
Oh my god!
Ooh, this one!
This one's it, Eddy!
Huh?
Careful, look behind you!
There's some annihilation shit going on.
Oh, wow!
Alien tentacles?
Hold on, I'm gonna get a selfie with that.
Do you want me to pose for it?
If you want, yeah.
I can hear a monster.
Me too.
This guy is plus two skulls dangerous, so...
Ooh, what was that?
Hello?
Evil.
Ooh, this place is pretty spooky.
A little.
Doki, you good?
I like the echoing.
I know, me too.
The ambiance is good.
Wait, Doki, you're good.
You saw her torso outside.
I'm asking her.
I know she's watching right now.
I'm being haunted by the spirit of Doki.
I can hear her.
Stop taking my shtick, man.
Is there nothing in here?
No, there's nothing in here.
Let me go the other way.
I guess we can check the security cameras.
Hold on.
Do you hear him?
What did you let him do?
I took a picture!
Where's your camera?
I took a picture.
You're alive.
You have no leg.
Let's go.
You are missing a leg.
I'm 50% health.
The camera!
I got some great footage.
This thing ate my legs.
It came out.
There was no way I could go anywhere.
What do you mean?
Slap the table.
You can do that?
Wait, what do you mean slap the table?
What are you talking about?
You made a loud thump noise.
I don't know.
You thought it was the game, but it was me.
It was me, Dio!
It was me, Tokiola!
Did she get the camera?
Look at that, Mit.
You died with the pro camera.
Yeah, but I didn't die immediately, so...
You got the theory out.
Nobody was willing to take the risk but me.
I got some great footage.
What cause?
There was no...
I'm gonna die going down the ladder.
It's gonna be so fucking embarrassing.
No, it's not.
It's gonna be my little alien photo.
She made it.
I know.
I was scared for a second.
There's still a lot of time, but I guess because we're all dead, you know...
Uh-oh, what's that sound?
Is there something down there?
Crawling?
Oh, there's a guy over there.
No, she needs to take a picture.
Turn around, live!
There's a big guy.
It's true.
Who's reading this paper anyway?
She got the camera, right?
Yeah, we got the camera.
It's good, guys.
We're good.
Wait, that still counts as my photo, right?
I mean, it's like... it's an important thing.
I took the photo.
Let's see if it counts.
I got his little feet.
Oh, that's me!
Oh, that's you, don't you?
That's you before you died.
Yeah, I actually took that.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, that's crazy.
Yeah, level 2?
I wanna know where the big monster is.
You saw the big monster photos?
He was persistent, though.
That was scary.
Okay, now that I know how hard it is to take photos, these photos are actually really, really good.
I know, right?
Oh my god.
Like, this one is so epic.
The one in front of the crotch.
Like, these are really good.
Yeah, these are actually really good.
This one looks like he's running away.
Yeah, the selfie ones are really hard.
Wait, someone said you should be able to pick up all dropped cameras.
Oh, really?
Okay, I threw mine for you.
But I didn't know if I could actually not.
But it's free.
It's free to get another one.
Scandal.
You can cover the scandal between a drugless and alien.
You're obsessed with this photo.
Stop being jealous of my love life, huh?
Okay?
It's a pretty good photo, I'm not gonna lie.
Are you guys ready?
On my way.
I'm ready.
Apparently, the big monsters appear in the last minute.
So we should just chill?
So if we chill by the helicopter, we should be good.
Zinky zoogle.
What the hell?
We just stay until the last minute, then.
Yeah, if we chill by the helicopter, we should be good.
Live life on the edge.
Oh, you hear that?
I hear something going...
I didn't hear it.
Oh, I see a green light.
Have we been there before?
That green light?
We got a different way because we didn't go up to the roof immediately.
Oh, true.
Wait, no, this is the same way to the same place.
Oh, we never went forward.
Oh my god, lady.
She's just like on a casual jog.
We could go this way and go into that main building.
We didn't go there last time.
We didn't go into the main building.
What could go wrong?
Exactly, guys.
Helicopter on the right there is where you turned into a pancake.
That's me.
That's where I was.
That's where you were.
Oh, so there's a whole different section over there that we could go up eventually.
That's cool.
Yeah, we go to the side, right?
Right here?
Oh, no, we went in that one last time.
Yeah, well, you guys went there last time.
I was dead.
Well, you know, some of us.
Oh, no, it's the same building.
What?
It is the same building.
Two doors, same building.
That's weird.
Oh, wait, no, the benches are different.
The fuck?
No, different building.
Oh, there's some monster bloody and stuff in here.
Oh, goopy.
Wait, pose next to her, pose next to her.
Emo over you.
Oh, there's something in here.
There's something in here.
Did something just open the door?
Hello?
Oh, I saw it.
A little thing just ran by.
Hello?
Is it that fucking bat creature again?
I swear to God.
It's a little baby.
It's a little cat with a baby thing.
It just ran through that doorway.
A little baby?
Can we kick the baby?
Go kick the baby, Doki, see what happens.
Yeah, do it.
Where'd he go?
I'm scared of a little baby.
Why is a baby two skulls?
I couldn't possibly imagine why.
You should definitely go find out.
Where is he?
Guys, where's the little baby, guys?
It's right behind me.
Oh, I see what you did there.
Little baby.
She didn't notice.
No, I know she didn't.
She lacks critical information.
I'm not a baby.
What's this?
What is that?
Nothing.
Is it a breaker box?
Doesn't do nothing.
Is this going to be one of those games like Lethal Company kind of where if you find a monster, you're basically just dead?
I know.
I think that's what the traps are for.
Oh, bloody!
Jesus Christ.
Alright, guys, do a pose.
I'm not letting you get the best photo.
You do a pose.
Okay, fine.
Hello.
Whoa!
We got it, we got it.
There's a...
This looks like a pool next to it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh.
Wait, do it again, do it again.
It's too good.
I'm trying not to waste my stamina.
I'm like, trying to keep the doors closed behind us so that we hear if something's coming up behind us.
Oh, that's a good idea.
You're so smart.
That's why she lived and we died.
I know.
I mean, you died because you jumped off a fucking building, but yeah, okay.
I mean, that's exactly why I'm not smart enough.
This room is huge.
Wait, there's more.
There's more Annihilation stuff over there.
Where?
I thought it looked like Annihilation.
Annihilation?
It's in our life.
It's a movie.
It's a movie where you go into this world and then you get absorbed into it.
Ew!
It's about a prism that instead of refracting light, it refracts DNA.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You look like you're kind of pissing on it, not gonna lie.
Where is a little baby?
Is that weird?
What was that?
It's the radio.
It's a radio broadcast.
That's freaky.
Oh wow, we're at the news station.
We should see if there's a way out of this building, but not like having to go all the way back.
It's gonna take forever.
It's a little spooky, not gonna lie.
It is a little spooky.
What happens if you stand on it?
Don't try it.
Probably nothing good.
Alright guys, are you ready?
Are you doing that again?
Wait, we can be the news now.
Oh my god, you're right!
Wait.
My fellow American.
What?
Oh!
Ran so fast!
I got a cool photo though!
And you kept your leg!
Yeah.
I hear it.
I'm out of battery on my flashlight, just a heads up.
You're out of battery?
Uh oh.
Yeah, uh oh.
Wait, that's not good.
The baby's back.
Where's the baby?
I don't know, but I can hear him.
New York is under attack.
We should probably get away.
I think so too.
Yeah, I don't think a steady is a good idea.
No, it's probably not.
Alright, let's leave it.
I'm watching your back, I'm watching your back.
Thanks very much.
Oh, I'm so fucking dead, it's so dark.
Oh gosh.
We used the camera for the night vision.
There's goop on the floor.
Wait, that's a trap, isn't it?
It could be.
We don't have a survivor though to test it.
I mean, we have three survivors right here.
Excuse me, I'm a journalist.
Oh wait, this is a dead end.
Lethal company ass looking fucking car.
I know!
I wonder if these are randomly...
Wait, this is also a dead end.
This place sucks.
We could try and book it out the way we came.
What about the left side?
Oh, there's a bed over here.
These doors are open.
Oh, what's this?
Oh wait, this is I think where we came from.
I'm coming.
Oh, hello.
I'm literally right here.
Goodbye.
Alright.
There's gonna be doggies.
I hate when I leave a room, I spawn inside someone's fucking head and it scares me because I see your eyeballs.
Is that a dude with a gun?
That's a dude with a gun.
There's a man with a bazooka.
Big monster!
He's here!
How do we get the shot?
Oh my god.
Should we go?
Look at that guy!
Come on military man, do your job!
There's like a small guy at his feet too.
We
gotta get her...
We need to get her camera, yeah.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
Alright, I'm going for it.
I'm running for it.
Oh you got it?
Ok nice.
Run, run, run.
Oh god, I'm out of stamina!
Are you alive?
I like how the helicopter pilot is totally fine here with the doors open and everything.
Oh we're fine too.
It's fine.
That wasn't the last minute.
Yeah!
Ok, ok.
I have a pro camera, I'm like, you know...
I was out of footage!
Look at him, he's so cute.
Wow, he's so cute.
Oh yeah, miss pro camera.
You got his ass.
The picture of the ass got more points.
That one's still good.
That guy was a lot of...
Nice!
Should we even like wait for the small guys?
All the pictures of the big...
Like all the best photos were of the big guys.
Yeah, I feel like we should just wait for the Darwin award.
Wait for the helicopter until they show up.
Here, someone else can use the pro camera if you want.
Oh, we can actually buy another one if you want to.
I can get a pro flashlight instead, maybe.
Oh yeah, maybe.
Oh, there we go.
Scared me.
I will get a pro flashlight this time then.
Nice.
Is this the pro camera?
That's me.
Guys, look, there I am, next to the dinosaur.
Do we need another flashlight?
We can take another flashlight.
No, I don't think you're in this one.
Yeah, I'm in... No, not in the one that won, but I was second place.
There you go, pro flashlight obtained.
I was in this one, look.
Oh yeah, that's you.
Flashlighter.
Flashlighter!
Yeah, he has got the picture!
Okay.
There's some more flashlights there so we can all have one.
Yeah!
Noki, did you get a flashlight?
Oh yeah, I got it.
Hell yeah.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go get some big guys.
Let's get some good photos.
Alright, so we just gotta live until one minute or something.
Or two minutes?
He showed up in the two minute mark.
Yeah, it wasn't one minute left.
It was more time than that.
The monster's stomach.
The more photos we get though, the better we do.
So it's still worth getting the others because we got 5000 points which included all the other photos.
Oh, true.
I feel like the big monsters show up like here.
So we can't be in this area.
You've come so far.
If we just stand here waiting for the monster, it will just obliterate us.
That's true.
We shouldn't be like, that's what's gonna happen.
Cool.
Spooky.
Spooky music.
I like the lanterns.
I feel like peeking through other people's windows.
Don't take photos in there.
Dude, did you take a picture?
Is someone changing?
Wow.
I bet you when the monster shows up, you could use this ladder to get a really good shot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll get pose in front of it.
That's how they get the poses, like staring at the monster all epic.
It's like a movie poster.
What am I stuck on?
Oh, there's a panorama.
Oh, it's a mall.
I wanna go to the mall.
Let's all go to the mall tonight.
Alright, let's go.
I'll provide flashlight services first and so you guys don't waste yours.
Okay, are you sure?
Alright.
Wait, what's this?
You can do flashlight after.
What is that?
I think those are just lights going in the dark.
Did you hear that?
Oh, there's a big thing above us on the left part there.
I hear him.
Think you're a monster.
Where did he go, lad?
You're like the senior reporter.
Ew, I hear him again.
The one with the biggest flashlight.
You guys not hear him?
I think he's behind us.
He's like right in here.
Is he?
No.
He's like...
No, I think we're hearing our own footsteps.
No, I'm hearing...
No, no, no.
I'm definitely hearing him.
I think he's underneath us.
Oh, maybe under...
Under where?
Hello?
Are you a monster?
He is a monster.
This photo is art.
Oh, I thought...
He looks like he's sucking on his fingers.
The text is just literally pineapple?
There's nothing in there.
That is a dead end.
I think it's like...
Yeah, is it procedurally generated?
Because there's lots of stupid dead ends.
I think that's it.
I was thinking that earlier in the last one.
I mean, that's for replayability.
There, he's down there!
Oh, there, across.
Do you see it?
What the heck was that?
It just vibrated out of existence.
Yeah, I just saw that too.
Yeah, I saw that.
I couldn't even take a photo.
I was like, what?
And then it disappeared.
Oh, there's something in that room over there too.
Something just went past the camera.
Oh, I hear him.
That's fucking loud.
Simple.
No, I didn't get a picture.
Any points for that?
You go as a gerbil, gerbil.
There's a door here if you wanna go in.
Oh, there's a little baby thing as well.
It's like a rat.
I saw a rat.
Baby rat.
How do you see all these babies?
I've never seen the babies.
You don't wanna go in the place where the rat is?
We're going this way?
Alright.
Oh, you wanna go in there?
I'm fine with that.
You can go in there.
There was another place though where there was a little baby rat thing.
Oh, I thought I heard growling.
I think this is the same place.
Oh, there's a survivor.
Oh my god, he scared the heck out of...
Oh, I think he just died.
Nevermind, he tripped.
No, he's spinning.
He's spinning.
You good, buddy?
He's doing a little spin.
You good up, my guy?
What's this?
Oh, wanna get rich?
You don't wanna follow us.
We won't take you to die.
It says we can get rich going this way.
I think this just goes around in a circle.
Oh, does it?
No, pizza.
Pizza?
There's another door here.
Maybe it does go in a circle.
Oh, he is following us.
Oh, break room.
Wait, oh, what's going on in here?
Nevermind.
This goes back around to the start.
Yeah, we're at the start again.
This is where the monster was earlier.
I hear him.
Oh, he's right here.
He's right there behind the door.
I'm gonna open it.
Does anybody want...
Oh, here, I'll pose.
Isn't that the creature that took your leg out?
It might be.
Oh, the spinny Cthulhu thing is out here.
Did you get the photo?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it, I got it.
Nice, nice, nice.
It looks like a D&D beholder.
He's really right there.
He's gonna take your leg out.
Open the door.
I take the photo and then we close the door.
Okay.
I'll put the light on.
Here, tell me...
Oh, open the door.
Okay.
Alright.
3, 2, 1.
Oh, shit.
Ouch, ouch.
Am I okay?
I'm okay.
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
I don't know where he went.
Yeah, just shut the door.
This guy doesn't trust us anymore.
I'm good.
Don't worry about it.
The baby right?
Holy shit.
Don't worry about him.
It's okay.
Are we leaving?
The lawnmower.
Holy moly.
What do I look like?
Oh, you're missing most of your...
Oh, the big guy is here.
The big guy is here.
I'm almost...
I'm already dead, guys.
I'm already dead.
Get a picture of me with him.
I'm here.
Wait, is Doki dead?
There's actually a doorway here inside.
Like a cafe or something.
Oh, wow.
Is Doki dead?
I don't know where she went, actually.
I don't see her, like...
Oh, he pissed.
I'm leaving.
We should go inside or something.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Oh, wait, this is the same building again.
This feels very...
Oh, there's something on the left.
There's something on the left.
This feels very Lethal Company, like in the...
generation.
Oh, God.
We may need to leave.
I think so.
Let's go.
Let's go through the back streets and get away from the big guy.
Oh, God.
Like, turn right here, I guess?
He...
Yeah.
There should be...
I wonder if Doki's okay.
I'm okay.
Oh, there's...
Stop, stop, stop, stop!
You're alright.
Oh, God.
Run, run, run, run, run, run!
Get
my camera, please!
Live!
Get my camera, please!
I got some good shots!
I never even got to see what I look like.
I think Doki's still alive.
Yeah.
Oh, maybe not for long.
Oh, my God.
Get my camera!
It's right there!
Get my camera, please!
Of course she wouldn't.
It's under the car!
That sucks.
No!
Hold on.
It's under the car.
Oh, thank you, Ghost of Mint.
Oh, I see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This sucks for me.
She's got it.
Oh, motherfucker!
I'm good.
She's got this.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Don't die!
Go, go,
go!
Ghost of Mint!
Hey, what's up?
Oh, my God.
That was...
You're crazy.
You don't have an arm.
No!
What happened to you?
That's just how the game is.
Sometimes you lose an arm.
Sometimes you lose it all.
That's just the name of the game.
Dang it!
That guy got me on the ladder.
I was like...
Oh, I wonder if he'll be able to attack you.
I was wondering because you were right behind me.
Yeah, he did get...
I was climbing up.
How did you die?
What?
Mint got eaten by a dog.
No, the big guy.
Oh, you got eaten by the dog.
The big guy got me.
Oh, the big guy got you on the ladder?
That sucks.
Oh, whoops.
Don't skip.
Oh, there's your photo.
Look at his little dog.
Oh, that's good!
Oh, my God!
That was the dog eating my ass.
That's so good!
What the hell?
Oh, my God!
What the fuck?
Damn, that one's so scary.
That's like a true apocalyptic photo.
When he chomped you.
I went over.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, yeah.
I still survived.
I survived that guy twice and I survived the baby.
I like this one, too.
The rat just like ran towards you and didn't even stop.
He just took your leg out as he went.
He smelled my blood.
Oh, my...
I wish I could have shown you guys.
I wish it caught on camera.
You got a selfie with the big guy!
Oh, my God.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, did it even count?
Unfortunately, it didn't register as being with him.
No, but it sucked.
No, you got robbed.
I did.
Oh, my God.
This was supposed to be a photo with a rat right through you.
Yo, this was the rat mowing you down.
It was so fast, I didn't capture the moment.
Look at... I look like I'm really angry at you.
I'm like side-eyeing.
Are you sure I should do that?
I love this.
Alright.
We don't have money yet, so...
This is when I was peeping into people's houses.
Oh, you really did take a photo.
Okay.
Alright, your turn with the pro camera.
Oh, God.
I don't know if I can handle this responsibility.
It can be the flashlight if you want.
Yeah, take the flashlight.
Okay.
Alright.
Another day on the job.
Days.
Oh, do we have a standard flashlight?
Oh, no, you guys.
I do, I do.
I have one.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, I got...
Oh, I didn't have one before.
Oh, no, I did.
Yeah, I got eaten.
You did.
I didn't get it though.
I was too busy getting your camera.
No, that's more important, I'd say.
There's a duplicate mechanic.
So, the same-ish object.
We're all professionals here.
We are.
Professionals.
I knew my journalism degree would come in handy.
I don't have a journalism degree.
I know.
As soon as we're here.
Who is reading this newspaper?
Who's still alive to be reading this?
I wonder what the blue light means.
I feel like it has to be important, but it hasn't told us anything about it yet.
Well, I feel like now that the internet is down and everything, you know, this is like literally...
literally like the only thing to read now.
Oh, true.
I feel like, yeah, I'm pretty sure these monsters have taken down all of the internet.
The 5G's.
5G's.
The 5G rays that's turning the front.
Even if the world ends, we got you covered.
BS insurance.
We are professionals.
Which way do you want to go?
There's a building behind us and a building in front.
Oh, we didn't go to that building.
We didn't go to that building.
Very briefly, but not long enough, so we can go look.
I don't think there's really a difference.
I'm gonna be honest.
No, I think it's all like randomly generated.
Don't go crypto.
Well, this is different.
Oh, okay, a little bit, yeah.
Wanna get rich?
Sure.
Hello.
No growls yet.
We're here to get rich.
I forgot I had the pro camera, so one of my photos is just some dude running down the street.
Stop!
I am scared.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Oh, it's the news station.
It's the news station.
God.
Okay.
I am scared.
It's really dark in here.
Oh, hey, there's his TV.
Security.
I wonder if it ever actually shows anything useful.
It hasn't so far.
Hello, intercom.
Hello.
It's scary not having a flashlight, actually.
I know, it is.
I don't think there's anything else in here.
There are no more doors here?
There's a door across from us over here.
Oh, let's go over there, yeah.
Ooh, blue light.
Hello?
Oh, we're in the news station room now.
China 5 News here to report on these alien sightings.
Hmm.
I guess this is another news station.
Oh, oh, what's that?
Uh-oh.
Wait, what's that sound?
What's that sound?
What?
Oh, oh!
It's the baby!
I got a picture of the baby.
I got him, I got him, I got the baby, I got the baby!
Let me fucking squeeble.
I got a squeeble.
Where'd he go?
He's apparently chasing us, so we might wanna be...
Oh god, oh god.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I do not wanna give you my legs!
He's coming!
He's...
Ah, baby!
There's a baby!
I'm jumping.
I'm jumping down.
Hello.
Hey, you guys good?
Yeah!
I don't think this guy can get us from here.
I too am good.
Where are you?
Yeah, he can't get me.
I'm on the high ground now.
Oh, okay.
I'm like on the ceiling of the news station bit.
Oh, nice!
We got the baby.
We got lots of good stuff going on here.
Yeah, we have all the good photos.
Yeah.
Wait, there's something over there.
Do you see that?
What?
Oh, that.
That's probably some alien matter.
You wanna go post by it?
Yeah, I'll take a picture of that.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'll post next to it.
I'll come with you.
Which way are you guys going?
I'm still just hiding on the rooftop bit.
We're on the table.
Yeah, we're just chilling.
We're just chill, guys.
Oh my god, there's something behind you!
It's me.
Oh!
Wait, there's something on the other side of the...
No, no, literally, there's something that just went over there.
Hold on.
Oh.
Who's that?
Was it not...
Was it the baby?
It looked like it was the baby.
You scared me.
I don't think it was the squeaker.
Oh, shit!
When did that show up?
We opened the door.
Oh, yeah, we got that.
Oh, there's a dead guy there, too.
Uh-oh.
I hear him.
I hear it.
I hear him growling.
I hear him walking.
There's enough room for three people up here, Lime.
Oh, there's something on the stairwell up there.
Oh, there is?
Oh, they're all up here.
Through that door over there, yeah.
They're camping us!
What is this, New York?
Look, this is New York.
We should skedaddle.
Yeah.
We should really leave.
I think we should leave.
How do we get out?
Oh, let's go up the stairway here.
Didn't you say it's on the stairwell?
Are they camping?
Yeah.
No, through the door.
Let's through the door.
Okay.
Uh, I think to get out, we go back this way?
Uh...
Can we come through here?
This looks right.
Yeah, because we closed all the doors.
And there was a lantern.
Yeah, yeah.
And then up here?
Uh-huh.
See?
Oh, yeah.
I would never lead you astray with my horrific sense of direction.
Uh -huh.
Wait, what's...
This is the exit over here.
Yeah, okay.
This way, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, that's the exit.
Do we want to leave or...
Oh!
I think we might...
What?
What is that?
I don't know.
Do you want a photo of it before we go?
Yeah, sure.
Okay.
Last photo before we go.
It's kind of stompy.
Yeah, I was going to say it's big.
It's a big boy.
Oh, there it is!
It's a stalker!
Stalker, no stalking!
Oh, we are going to shamble.
Come here.
We shamble.
Oh, I missed it.
Wait.
Oh, don't pause!
Don't pause next time!
I'm out of photos.
Running!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
There is a dog right next to you.
You are going to die.
Damn,
she lived!
How did she live?
My camera!
You guys, I got that epic shot!
No!
Nobody will see it!
I don't even know where my camera is.
It's actually missing.
Oh, wait.
No, it's right there.
She had her pro flashlight.
She's right here.
No, I'm over there!
To be fair, what was I supposed to do?
What else was I supposed to do?
I got the best shot!
Nobody will ever know it.
I died for the journalism.
Someday somebody will see my camera!
And we'll go!
Oh, hi Lime!
You died!
Oh no!
No, Doki!
Doki, don't be a coward!
Oh my god, typical Doki...
Doki coward bird.
How did you die, Lime?
I guess we'll never know.
How did you die?
Did you know that that big guy can actually snatch you off of the rooftops if he's not distracted?
Because he did.
I got such a good photo of him.
And now we'll never see because Doki decided to leave.
She doesn't care about the journalism!
Let's get the plane first and wait for it.
There's my photo.
There's a photo of you.
These are going to be the only photos of him before he died.
There's the beautiful cab.
And then there's the stalker.
Oh wow, what's that one?
You couldn't even get his face!
A picture of the big guy's dick.
Fantastic.
Good job, everybody.
And I took us to the next level!
You're welcome, everybody.
Look at that.
My beautiful photo.
Coward bird over here.
Coward bird.
My beautiful photo in the front page yet again.
What do you want to spend our money on?
MVP.
We need a pro camera.
We could each have pro cameras.
We could.
That's true.
But that does lower the amount of total photos we can take because it can only hold 7.
Oh true.
Yeah, that's like the disadvantage I guess.
The trade -off.
We could get like, sports shoes.
So we can run faster.
We could get more health too.
We could get a pair of sports shoes.
And then we could also maybe get a flashy camera.
Because that's like a good middle ground.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so let's do sports shoes.
And a flashy camera.
I can't believe I lived there.
That monster killed all the military men and I lived.
I watched that and I was like, oh she's dead for sure.
How the hell?
Yeah, I thought I was dead.
I wasn't looking at my screen anymore.
I was like, goodbye.
Don't let Doki...
Who wants the shoes?
Who wants the camera?
Don't let Doki take the... Okay, never mind.
She's just going to use it to run away and not do anything.
I think Lime should do it because she's been the camera picker up here.
Sick kicks, we're going.
Okay, I'll get it.
We don't have a flashlight because I mismanaged our money.
That's fine.
Oh, you have a flashlight?
Fantastic.
Someone else use it.
I got it, I got it.
We're good, we're good.
It's because Doki hasn't died.
Yeah, we're in crime level three now, I'm pretty sure.
Crime level?
Monster crime.
Real alien crimes here.
Those monsters.
God dammit.
Alien crime.
Ever since that monster became mayor, crime levels have risen.
What's special about this camera?
It's just a flash?
Yeah, it's got an inbuilt flash.
Okay.
10% extra points on photos.
Oh, okay.
Racist, that darn monster!
I can't believe streamers are being monstrous right now.
Isn't like people in Townsville hate monsters?
Oh look, we're so close.
To the helicopter.
The city of Townsville.
That's right, they don't deserve to work in our city.
Nice.
Oh, there's a building over to the right here.
Wait, there's one right here too.
Do you want to go to the city mall or whatever that building is?
Whichever.
I don't think it matters.
I feel like this one's closer, just a little bit.
Okay, what's up?
It's the same, we've been here before.
Have we?
Oh, it's the place with the helicopter.
Yeah.
I hear growling already.
Oh, he's right!
Nevermind, that's a man.
Help!
Oh God!
There's a baby!
Someone, someone!
I got you.
What the fuck?
I got a photo, don't worry.
I got the photo.
Oh, it's the fucking baby.
It's the fucking baby!
What's he doing?
Hey, get out of my shot, man.
Where's the baby?
Oh, he can see points.
Alright, don't worry, I'm okay, guys, if you were wondering.
Yeah, we're all great.
Yeah, we're fine.
Was that the baby that got me?
I didn't even see him.
No, it was a trap.
No, no, it was a trap.
He got dangled from the trap.
Oh my God, he just ran.
How is there so many monsters right off the bat?
I know.
Kids are on three stars.
Oh, he's right there.
Hello, baby.
We're both next to the baby.
Oh, never mind, he left.
Goodbye, baby.
Bye, baby.
Goodbye, little man.
Oh, I hear him.
I hope we don't just chase the baby.
Nah, well, I mean...
Oh, shit!
What is it?
Stalker.
Baby!
Where?
What did you see?
It was the stalker.
Remember the stalker that came out?
Yeah, you have to like...
I think he might be like that guy in Lethal Company where you have to see him in order for him not to murder you.
The bracken or whatever?
Yeah.
What the hell was that?
It was the stalker again.
What's going on in there?
Squishy noises.
It's really squishy.
We should photograph the squishy noises.
I'm gonna...
If you feel close to the thing, always emote.
Just press it.
Uh-oh.
I hear...
Oh, the baby killed him!
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
The baby killed him!
Hold on.
He's afraid of light.
The baby is afraid of light, I think.
Hold on.
How did the baby kill the fucking stalker though?
Wait, wait.
The baby is awesome!
Thanks, baby!
We appreciate you, baby.
He's standing there.
Oh, I can move this.
Oh damn, we can take it.
We can take it for a better photo.
Oh, he's so...
Okay, he doesn't stop like squishing once you pick him up.
Oh, there's a goop here.
I don't wanna step on that.
I don't either.
Put him on it, put him on it.
Nope.
Why are you following us, dude?
You have like no self-preservation instincts whatsoever.
Wait, maybe he can step through it.
We just parkour here?
Oh, true.
YOLO.
It's fine.
I think it's actually okay.
Are you gonna come?
So, I think the baby might get real scary if you don't have any light.
Yeah.
Cause the baby just fucking brutalized that thing.
Yeah, that...
Good for us.
That baby was just a little man, but like, he was a big boy.
Oh, a holder.
Uh-oh, what was that?
It's him right there.
Hey there.
Shiny.
You just chilling?
He's just chilling.
Yeah, he does the thing and he's screaming.
Oh, he's gonna vibrate?
See ya.
Bye.
I don't get what he does.
Maybe...
He's like, peace out.
He does a spin.
That's what he does.
He just is there for the vibe.
He doesn't really need to do anything.
Where are we going now after this?
That guy is still following us.
I know.
Are you okay, man?
I think he's gonna follow us until we like get out of the house.
The house?
I'd hate for this to be my house.
I know.
Yeah, my big ass house right here.
Uh-oh, what was that?
Oh, Jesus.
Hello again.
What was that?
It was the cthulhu.
Oh, it's him again.
Yeah, he's just chilling.
I don't really understand his bit.
Oh!
What is that?
It's him again.
Isn't that the same guy?
It sounds like him, yeah.
Maybe.
Meow.
Moe goes minting.
Where do you get your photos printed?
Oh, this leads to the main entrance.
Oh, does it?
Yeah.
Oh, we should go back.
I think...
I think it should be enough time for a big guy.
Probably.
Yeah, we're right here.
Yeah, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Hello.
We didn't go this way.
But there's only like...
It seems like he killed the other...
thing, so...
Yeah, there's not a whole lot in here anymore.
Yeah.
Yeah, I feel like all...
It's just a baby now.
Yeah, it's just a baby.
Just one...
whole baby.
Oh, and he is out.
He's here.
Oh my god, I'm stuck.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, sexy lady!
Wait, I'll jump over.
Oh, there's a mini-man.
There's a mini-man.
Oh, what did I get killed by?
What did I get killed by?
What was there?
There was nothing there!
What did I get killed by?
I got you, I got you.
Manhole worm?
What?
I got killed by the manhole worm!
Oh my god, Doki.
Why do I always die?
I hate these fucking types of games, man!
Sexy lady, save me!
Oh my god.
You guys didn't get my camera.
No, I got your camera.
Oh, you did?
Okay.
I did, yes.
That's what her shoes are for.
That was amazing.
I saw that manhole cover moving and I was like, oh, that's weird.
Then you went over there and got...
I didn't even see!
I was like, what killed me?
That thing was around!
I took a picture of it.
You'll see it in a second.
Okay.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
I saw it pop up, too.
And that's the photo.
I hate that.
Ugh.
Sexy lady.
What on earth?
I didn't even see that guy.
That's me!
You didn't see the sexy lady?
I was busy trying to save this camera.
Your camera should be back on the desk.
My favorite photo has to be this one.
Oh, is it permanent?
No, it's because I picked it up for you.
Oh, that's right.
Oh yeah, here's when you were getting trapped, by the way.
Oh yeah, that's what it looked like.
You were like, what's going on?
I like how you got six shoes on as well.
It looks like that Fortnite thing where you can change your shoes no matter who you are now.
It looks like that.
Ugh.
There's the baby.
I thought that thing was going to pop back out of the manhole and eat me when I tried to get your camera.
Oh my god, I didn't realize there were like fucking traps too in the manhole.
That's crazy.
I didn't either.
That's so evil.
That's where you died.
I know.
Man, I thought it was the military guy shot me or something.
I was like, what the hell?
Oh no, no.
The bullets go through you.
They do?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got shot like they shot me, but I guess I lived.
It would be kind of harsh if you got friendly fired by those dudes on top of everything.
I know, actually.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll just say I'm pretty fucking rough.
Wait, you didn't see that giant tree monster?
No, I was legitimately like trying to deal with the thumper that was throwing cars.
Oh yeah, that guy was around too.
We're at two and a half.
We just gotta run.
I like the baby.
I wanna go to a different house.
I feel like we've explored that a lot already.
There was one on the right, but it seems as though the insides are just randomized.
I think so.
Wait, is there anything over here?
There's like a back street down here.
Yeah, we could try it.
You could also go up, but I don't think you can get onto the building.
I'm not sure.
I feel like it's just the Roothof perspective POV.
Yeah, can we get inside?
I assume not, but...
This feels like it's lit up for me to go in.
I know!
There's like weird lighting everywhere too.
Like this yellow light here.
Game design rules tell me I should be able to get inside that hut, but they...
On the pink light.
Wait, I think we just went in a circle a little bit.
We did.
We went to the alleyway.
At least we know there's another way.
We're back to Sushi Kyoto!
Why can't we go there?
Oh, there's somebody in there.
I don't think we want to.
He's like, no, this is my Sushi Kyoto.
There's another house over there we haven't gone to.
What, this one right here?
We might actually make it to level 5.
We're gamers.
Oh, it's this area again.
Yeah, I think we're randomized.
There's a little rat.
A rat?
Oh, the stalker!
Fuck off, stalker!
Stalker, no stalking!
Look at him go!
Wait, there's a trap.
There's a string trap nearby.
How do you know?
Because it went off on the camera.
Oh, look on the ceiling, I think, is where you'll see.
Yeah, I don't see it though.
Just knock me down if it gets me, I guess.
Oh, there's a weird humpback tick thing!
Ew!
What?
It was on here.
Humpback feature.
Stalker?
Stalker 5!
I got him.
Oh, there he is!
What the hell is that?
I told you, it's a weird humpback tick!
I'm gonna point at him.
Look at him go!
Shamble chasing.
What the heck?
Oh, I caught a selfie of that.
Ew, I hear something on the left.
There's a lot of stuff down here.
There's a lot going on.
I can ride again.
I feel like we don't even need to leave this front room.
I think we can just stay in here and things will come to us.
Stalker, no stalking!
I like the stalker.
The rat's in here.
Oh, wait, no, this is a headcrab.
There's a headcrab in here.
Oh!
Oh, what was that?
Oh, okay, nevermind.
You cannot take a picture of it through the glass, so you need to go in there.
There's the rat!
Rat, rat, rat, rat!
Little rat!
Oh, he's diseased.
Oh my god, where is he trying to go?
He's diseased.
Rattler.
We gotta try and get the headcrab.
I have a feeling as soon as that door opens, we're gonna be in trouble.
Okay, we're just letting him in.
Oh, someone's...
Not me, please!
I got it.
I got the photo.
It's okay, guys.
Oh, I didn't even die.
Oh, I'm out of...
I'm out of film, though.
Dang it.
Weird tick creature's back.
He's gone.
Where?
He went off to the left.
I feel like we definitely...
Oh, oh, something just died, I think.
Stalker, no stalking!
There's something else in here?
It's like a big guy.
Rat's coming back.
Watch your feet, watch your feet!
Where is he?
He just ran to the end of the room you guys went into.
Oh.
The hunchback thing is in here, too.
Oh, there's so many monsters here.
Hunchback tick creature thing.
Oh, he's coming up.
He's just chilling.
Can you take a photo with him?
Oh, god.
I'm running.
He's coming after me.
In a really slow kind of way.
What the...
Hey, booba.
I'm a journalist!
I have a journalist pass!
I'm journalist immunity!
There's no point in me staying.
I have no...
I have no film left.
Wait, where is...
Oh, at four I left.
Then go get some pictures.
Then this guy will show up.
I feel like...
Yeah, big guy is probably already outside.
I don't know.
We didn't spend that long in here.
Yeah, we're kidding.
Let's see.
Oh, yes, he is!
Oh, no, he's up!
He's here!
Here, get a picture of me in front of him!
No, take a picture of me!
He's taking a good perspective picture.
Got one.
He's crazy looking.
Guys, our plane is on the other side.
No, it's not.
Oh, uh...
You're right.
Guys, we locked ourselves in.
Oh, no, he lost interest.
He lost interest.
We're so tiny.
We're fine.
Yeah.
Okay, I think we can head back, right?
I feel like we want to get, like, oh.
Circling around.
Oh, oh, just kidding.
He's coming.
Oh, lord.
Oh.
Wait, did all of us just fall through the fucking world?
Yes, yes.
Except Doki.
Are you dead?
Yeah.
Did you fall through the planet?
Yes, I did.
Okay, me too.
I think, did Doki...
I think, did Doki kill us?
How did this happen?
No.
I don't think she did.
She's gotta grab our stuff.
She's not going to.
No, Doki would totally pay attention to the blue highlighted cameras on the floor.
Yeah.
She's got this, bro.
Just go, Doki.
Where do you think she is?
Let's go have a look.
Wait, why is she just standing inside?
Oh, we dropped our bodies in the front of the chopper, so we can...
Yeah, yeah, no, they're right by the front of the chopper, so it should be really easy for her to get the stuff...
Yeah, she just has to go.
There's only three minutes left.
She's gotta go.
Oh, she's got this.
As long as she doesn't get... Oh, there's like a stalker, right?
Oh, god.
Like, sometimes I can actually hear you guys when you're dead.
There's so many, there's so many monsters.
There's so many monsters.
I don't like this, girl.
Yeah, it'll go great.
Okay, I can make it.
I can make it.
Come on, Dookie coward.
Let's go.
She just keeps going in and out.
Oh, she's just hiding.
Doki, please.
Doki, come on.
Come on.
Okay, I can make it.
I can make it.
Come on.
I believe in Dookie bravery.
The bravery?
I don't know.
Luck?
I think she has that stat more against her.
Or like, for her.
There she goes.
Oh, she's stuck.
Maybe?
Oh, my god.
Dookie, Dookie.
It's everywhere.
Hi.
Mint and I got pressed through the world.
Yeah, we actually no-clipped through the map and fell over.
There's a photo in Discord where I'm just looking up at the floor from below.
We got no-clipped into oblivion.
Yeah, I was like, oh, I'm doing well.
I hesitated.
There were so many monsters everywhere.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're totally gonna get all 3,000 points that we need in this one run.
Whoever said... we have two runs.
Oh, never mind, we have one run.
No, this is our last run.
Whoever said we were gonna get to level 5, they cursed us.
They cursed us.
It's totally their fault.
We had such a good run, too.
Dang.
We all have to use all our photos.
We have to use... we have to take as much as we can.
Yeah, don't waste on anything.
And make sure we don't get doubles, too.
Alright, we got this.
No.
I don't think we've got this.
There was like 5 fucking monsters outside my door.
Like, how the fuck was I gonna get out of there?
It's such a shame because we no-clipped through the planet, it dumped our bodies by the helicopter and our cameras.
Yeah, everything was... everything was right there.
Yeah, everything was right there.
Oh my god.
The big red guy didn't block the only way across I would've ran.
I feel like we should go to the door to the right side.
That had so many monsters.
Okay, this one right here.
Yeah, the right side.
Oh wow, the truck is already overturned.
It's okay, I can move it with my head, apparently.
It gives us a little bit of a covering, you know?
Yeah, that's true.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, we don't have a single flashlight anymore.
And there's something zip-zooming around at the top.
Oh, I see him, too.
There's something at the top, do you see it?
Yeah, I see it.
I'm posing, I'm posing.
Uh-oh, what's that?
What the fuck is that?
I don't like that.
Um, everything's wobbling.
It's like a spider's man, it's called a polpo, apparently.
Polpo!
Hey, polpo.
Yo, polpo.
I cannot see anything so fucking dark.
You can see a little bit better through your camera lens, but then you're gonna waste the battery.
Oh, you don't waste battery, the thing is just the camera film.
Oh, it is?
No.
Yeah, it's not battery.
Oh, what was that?
Oh god, it's a little vent gremlin.
Great.
And a stalker.
Yeah, I saw that.
Another vent gremlin.
Leave me alone.
Oh my god.
What's he gonna do, huh?
This guy's a dick.
Oh, he'll take your leg out.
Yeah, he will actually take your leg out.
Yeah, but I have a high ground.
He fucking murdered me and it was really funny.
Yay.
Oh, there's something in there.
Oh, it's another, it's the vent crawler again.
Hey, buddy.
Oh, vent crawler.
Those guys suck.
Wait, let me in.
Where'd the spider go?
I had so many good photos too last time.
He's coming.
Oh, there he is.
Ah!
What the hell?
Ugh.
I'm fine.
You good?
Yeah.
Glad to hear it.
I'm leaving.
I don't know.
Should we try and take, like, wait for the big guys to show up and take photos outside or something?
Because I can't see anything.
Do I still have my leg?
No.
Well, you do.
He does not.
I don't, yeah.
I lost a leg.
Oh, okay.
I'm okay too.
Oh, so annoying.
I'd like to get a picture of the stalker.
Oh, there's another fucking beholder in here too.
A what?
Go away, vent crawler.
Okay, at like six minutes we have to get out because that's when the big guy spawns in, I feel.
Okay.
Where's the military when we need them?
What's the point of funding the military when they don't show up when we want them to?
Hello?
Is anybody coming out?
Come on.
I think we're safe now.
I didn't realize there was a zoom in.
Never mind.
You're such an idiot.
Is that a real guy?
Wait, you haven't been zooming in?
No.
Oh.
What was that?
Hello?
Are you guys...
good now?
Hello?
There's so many things.
There he is!
Oh, there's the stalker.
I got him.
Woo!
He's so fast.
I didn't get him.
We have to pretend we can't see him so he gets closer.
Yeah.
Gotta be like, I sure hope no big stalker comes and sneaks up behind me.
I don't notice him.
It's a shame if someone just shows up behind me.
I'd sure hate it if a vent crawler...
ate my ass right now.
I actually would hate that.
Oh, you're up here.
That's a good idea.
I think we should split up and go in different directions.
Oh, yeah.
That's a great idea.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Let's split up and look for clues.
I've already split...
Oh, there's a little zoomer guy in there.
Zoomer, zoomer, zoomer, zoomer.
Oh, I forgot to...
The pompa thing is still at the top there.
Yeah, we're not gonna...
Oh, there's another zoomer.
Yeah.
I don't really know what this guy does.
I don't know.
He also seems to be not...
Oh, stalker!
Dang it, stalker!
Oh, stalker, no stalking!
No!
I got quite a few points from him.
I missed...
Oh, what's that?
I'm not getting any of these.
What the hell?
You see that on the other side?
No.
Yeah.
What's that?
Although the pompa is still over there.
Oh, there's the pompa.
There he is.
Hey, pompa, come say hi.
Don't be shy.
Alright, we should go out.
It's five-minute mark.
Don't be shy, pompa.
Okay.
It's a five-minute mark.
You should be outside.
I wasted all my photos.
Oh!
Oh, there's soldiers!
There's a big guy.
We should try to take photos outside the helicopter or something.
I can't run!
My health is too low!
I'm going!
I'm trying!
She's still here!
I can't run!
I'm coming.
I'm this lady.
This lady is faster than me.
Because you've not got a leg.
We made it.
To this.
It all comes down to this.
We made it up.
We made it up, honey.
No, you didn't!
It all comes down to our 30 photos.
Our 30 photos.
Let's go.
Come on.
Alright.
I believe.
The drama.
It worked!
That's a really good one.
Thank you.
That's a nice one.
OK, that's good.
That's a good one.
What?
Is that not a double?
That should be enough, I think.
Hell yeah, we made it.
We made it!
Oh my god, we made it.
Both selfies.
God, look at that.
Guys, three out of four are headliners.
I personally like this one better than this one.
Yeah, I actually like that one.
Yeah, that one was good.
Do you want to do a flashy camera?
There's also an SD camera that gives you 15 pictures.
Which is pretty hot.
I feel like more photos is good.
Sure, OK.
We have $200.
What do you want to spend it on?
Another camera or some normal flashlights?
Oh, bravery.
We could give each other helmets.
We could spend two helmets for health.
How do you see what the points are?
Oh, I see it.
You know what, I'm going to order some helmets.
Because you know when you get attacked by a bad creature that eats your leg?
I think having a helmet on will save your life.
Oh yeah, that's a good idea.
It's basically the same body part.
Wait, you want me to wear the helmet?
We got the helmet.
Wait, you don't just wear the helmet.
Oh no, you do.
I think it's because it's an item that you have to hold to get the benefit.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's on?
It's my special helmet.
Wait, you don't have it on.
Is mine on?
Yeah, yours is.
There's only two.
Oh, OK.
Well, you guys need the most.
Me?
Really?
Yeah, Lime is the most responsible here.
So, we are the ones with the helmets.
OK, does someone have the camera that takes tons of pictures?
Wait, how do you...
Yeah, here.
You got it?
OK, that's fine.
You take it.
Just having it causes it to be yours.
Oh, is it on my head now?
No.
When you scroll off of it, it will be.
Yeah, there you go.
You're good.
Hey, guys.
My mom bought this helmet for me for the bus.
Wait, before we go, I need to use the bathroom.
I've been hydrating.
OK.
I'll be right back.
Push her in.
Is it Thursday?
No, it's Wednesday today, isn't it?
It's Wednesday, yeah.
My sense of time is all messed up because I've been sick, I've not been streaming on my normal day.
So, I'm like, what day is it?
Are you getting proper rest?
No, I spend most of the time trying to sleep and then not being able to sleep because I can't breathe.
And then falling asleep because I'm so tired, so it's like all over the place.
Yeah, it's the worst.
I have like no concept of time anymore because I'll try and go to bed and then I'll lie there from like 2am to 9am.
And I'm so tired and I didn't get any sleep.
And then I'll get up and I'll go and sit down in a chair and I'll fall asleep in the chair instead for three hours.
And then I wake up and it's 6pm and I'm like, what the fuck?
But if you're in the chair, you're like sitting up, maybe that helps your nose not be so...
Yeah, no, when I'm sitting up, I'm less clogged, so it's nicer, I think.
You sound terrible.
Thanks.
Yeah, I was sick not too long ago, I get it.
It was rough.
Hello, I'm back.
Welcome back.
Did you wash your hands?
Yeah, I washed my hands.
Thanks, mom.
I'm so proud of you.
There are the two daughters that needs the helmet.
Times Square-ish.
Wait, is this a new location?
It's back to Times Square, but it's more dangerous.
God, you look like my...
My two kids where I don't trust you enough to have your safety helmets on.
Yeah, we have the leashes on too.
The harnesses and everything.
Oh my God, mom, there's...
What?
He died already!
How?
Did you just...
You were alive for three seconds.
Well, kid helmet is mine now.
I ran into a car.
I saw...
Was the car moving?
I got run over by a parked car.
I wonder if something is like underneath the cars.
I don't think there was.
I think she literally just got physics to death.
You know like Source games where something is like vibrating and it causes...
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Velocity collision damage.
I think she did that with a car.
Oopsie.
Well, that's not great for us.
Let's go in here.
It'll be funny.
That's a horrible sound.
Why is it making creepy noises?
I don't know.
I was gonna say it's a horrible noise.
Oh God, every time.
Mint, do you want the special camera Doki had?
Because I've got the flashlight, so here you go.
OK, if you trust me with that.
I take more photos.
I trust you with it.
It'll be great.
Oh, we're in the same room as...
What the fuck?
Oh, hey, Cthulhu.
Oh, sorry, Beholder.
I get them mixed up sometimes.
That guy.
Who else is in here?
Hello?
Oh, look.
Wait, I hear something.
Goop.
Where?
Oh, right there.
You wanna pose in front of it?
Sure, I'm just trying to figure out what that weird bleeping noise is.
I know, that's what I'm wondering.
OK, anyway, hold on.
Oh, that's not terrifying at all.
Oh my god.
Holy...
What the hell?
Cool.
I'll follow wherever you wanna go.
Wait, is it... I think it's that.
Oh my gosh, it's a mine.
Oh, there are mines.
Because we're truly the most lethal of companies right now.
Yeah.
OK, interesting.
So there's a couple in here.
Oh,
I wanna sneeze like constantly.
It's fucking awful.
Sneeze.
Oh, there's a dude being eaten.
Oh yeah, there is.
I think we're gonna stick pose in front of it because of the height.
Yeah, let's get us both in there.
Oh, there's a guy in here for sure.
Oh.
It's just a boulder.
Did you get a good picture?
Oh, he's coming up!
He's coming up!
Hey, what's up?
I got you both.
I don't know what he got.
No, I mean, I get weird music when he looks at me, so maybe if you let him stare at you too long, bad stuff happens.
Oh, maybe.
I think, I kinda remember boulders, if you look at them, you go nuts, so maybe just, I don't know, don't stare at him.
Oh, he's up there too.
Oh, yeah, I'm starting to get the weird music or something weird.
My vision's starting to go funky.
What a dick.
Yeah, go away.
Oh, there's some goop I will overhear.
And that's a trap right there?
Or was?
I can't tell.
There's a goopy thing there too.
Sick, sick, sick.
I hear something.
Yeah.
I hear something mouth-breathing.
Oh, there's a mine in here.
Oh, wait, no, this is where we, I think this is where we started?
Is this back where we started?
I can't see anything.
I don't know.
Oh, wow.
Wait, what the fuck?
This is a door to...
Turn around, look, impossible geometry.
It's a literal suicide door.
Okay, that's perfect for this moment.
How many pictures did you get?
Do you think we should just go outside and take some pictures of the carnage outside?
I have 8 out of 15 left.
So...
Pretty nice.
I know, I got, we got...
I got tons of camera things to do.
Is there anything in here?
Let me see if the mine does anything.
Oh, yeah, you do get points for the mine, not a lot, but...
Is there anything in here?
Besides...
Mines and the beholding?
Oh, there's another headcrab thingy.
Oh, great.
Or, you know, like a head muncher.
Do you hear an air raid siren?
Yes.
Okay, then.
That doesn't sound very good.
Hello?
Is it coming from the...
Do you think there's something sweet outside as a result?
Oh, could be.
I'm gonna go look.
Yeah, let's go look.
That's our sign to be real journalists.
Holy shit!
Oh, what the hell is that?
Oh, where's the...
Which way is the...
Oh, that way.
My fucking god is staring at me.
Oh, he's staring at...
Oh, wow.
He's tossing shit at us, what a dick.
Yeah.
Oh, that's nice.
There's a car.
That's good.
We could just hang out here and take some pictures and then whoever dies first, you pick up their camera and just leave.
True.
There's like... Is there anything else around here?
No?
No, there's a dude running towards the tornado which is like an interesting battle strategy.
I don't know how that's gonna work out for him.
Great survival instincts.
I'm gonna get closer to it.
Ok, maybe you could pose or something and I'll take a picture of you.
I'm posing.
Turn back towards me.
There we go.
Sick picture.
Alright.
There's a monster.
There's like a selfie monster over there.
Oh, there's a couple actually.
His name is Clubby.
Clubby.
Cause he's got a club.
Oh, he ran away.
What a bitch.
Oh, I got a lot of stuff in that picture.
Ok, nice.
I just wanted to selfie with him.
Well, I have two more so I guess I'll just take some...
Yeah, I mean we can wait a couple more minutes.
See if anything cool shows up in the last minute or two.
This guy isn't very threatening.
No.
He's actively moving away from us while staring us down.
He's like...
He looks like he should be so intimidating but nothing's happening.
Yeah, I mean it was really scary when we spawned right next to him.
And then he was like, oh, I'm sorry.
I'll move for you.
Just get a vacuum, guys.
Come on.
Suck him up.
There's nobody here either.
It's just kinda chill.
Just be careful of the car that killed Doki, I guess.
Oh yeah, true.
Let me take a picture of her corpse.
The car casualty.
Hi Doki.
Are you still inhabiting your dead body over here?
Nice.
I'm out of photos.
I'm getting in because I'm out of photos.
Bye Doki.
We'll remember you.
I can take your corpse with us, actually.
Pequod, take us home.
I brought Doki with us.
Throw her into the tornado.
I don't... I didn't get Doki...
It was so fucking funny that we were like, man, you know, we gotta protect you with your safety helmet.
And then you walk into a stationary car and fucking die.
Use your helmet back, Doki.
Oh yeah.
I thought it was fun.
Nice.
That's a good photo.
Oh god.
Oh, look how cute I am.
Pequod's just selfies of you as a big guy.
I mean, he was really considerate.
He just chilled and let us do anything.
Yeah, he was really chill.
That's a good one.
That photo's good.
That's a really cool one.
Woo woo!
Oh, 4,000.
Wow.
50% of it on the first run.
Yeah.
Your helmet's back by the desk, Doki.
Okay, this helmet's made out of plastic.
There's no way.
I don't know.
You're made out of plastic, maybe.
Wait, who has the blue camera?
Oh, it's right here.
It's right there.
It respawned.
Oh yeah, it respawned.
There you go.
Alright, I'll use it then.
Yeah.
Alright, let's go.
Now I know cars are dangerous no matter what.
Never get in a car, guys.
Never get on top of a car.
Cars, not even ones.
Don't do it.
Cars.
Square-ish.
I like that guy.
He was easy, though.
Stop coughing.
I'm pretty sure you bought this helmet from a kid's section.
Oh, I hear something already.
Yeah.
Raki the raccoon!
Hey mister, did you know if you chat with me, you can get a good deal on your vehicle insurance?
Don't say I didn't do nothing for you.
Is there something over here?
I'm curious if we just stay outside the whole time, how things start appearing.
If they do, at least.
Like, you know?
Oh, that's true.
I wonder.
That's good.
There's a building.
Do you see?
Someone should go and camp that building and take really cool aerial shots.
Do you see that ladder over there?
Oh yeah!
Yeah, I can do that.
Wait, there's also a door over here.
Yeah, there is.
Best to be used.
So someone stay outside and the other people get photos just in case, like, something terrible happens when you just camp outside and we lose the run.
Explosion!
I'll stay outside.
Of course you will.
Come on, mid.
Let's go be brave.
Yeah, let's go do actual jobs.
She's screaming out.
She's yelling at us.
Yeah, she is.
Alright, let's see what we got in here.
Death, probably.
Probably.
Hello!
This is the first layout we ever had, I think.
I remember that head on the stairs.
Oh yeah, I think you're right.
It's like...
Oh, hey.
Oh.
What's going on?
Oh, there's something behind us?
Yeah, it sounds like there's a lot of stuff in here.
Yeah, it sounds creepy.
I don't really understand the beholder.
You get, like, fuck all points for him, too.
Where'd you go?
Oh, there you are.
I'm here, I'm here.
There's a creepy-crawly at the end of the card.
There's something around here.
Oh, that's the beholder again.
Oh, damn it.
Oh, it's a headcrab.
I'm gonna try and get a picture.
Oh, and the baby.
The baby here, too?
The baby, you need the flashlight.
Oh, I see him.
If I get hit by the headcrab, you need to knock it off of me.
You just walk up and press E.
Okay.
If you wanna get in, like, between them and emo...
It's me!
I got you.
I got a picture of him jumping on me.
Oh, watch out.
This guy's being aggressive.
Oh, God!
It's the leg biting!
What's happening?
Oh!
What the shit?
Um...
Uh...
Maybe we don't mess with that guy.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God!
My body won't stop splatting.
This is so annoying.
No.
100% not.
Goodbye, what?
Oh, Doki doesn't know.
What do you mean by that?
We're so safe.
Doki doesn't know.
Hold six minutes.
She lacks critical information.
Look at all your peers, though.
There's, like, gunshots here.
There's, like...
She's got the easiest job in the world right now.
Oh, my God.
I can't even be by my body.
It's so annoying sounding.
That's when you know I got the experience.
I left the room because it was doing, like, source physics glitch noises.
I was like, no, I'm gonna go hang out with Doki.
I know.
I'm gonna tell her to go get our cameras.
I don't know if she can hear us if she's not by our dead bodies.
Hey, go get our cameras.
I feel like I hear a ghost right now.
Oh, my God.
For some reason, when I jumped back in here, it blew up again.
What?
Oh.
I don't know.
I still...
I can see under the world map.
Oh, my God.
I think as I'm colliding with the floor...
I don't know what's going on.
Oh, my God.
The fuck is that?
Oh, is that the alien dog?
Oh, it's fast.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, shit.
Okay, but where's the tornado?
Doki, go get our cameras.
Guys.
I got such a good shot of the crab jumping at me.
She's never gonna get those cameras.
It's one of those special as well, I think, or at least a helmet or something.
Something's happening.
That's the tornado.
That's the air raid siren.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
Or alternatively, it's meteors from the sky and Doki's about to fucking die.
Oh, he spawned.
He's watching.
There he is.
It's time to go.
Don't drop.
Doki, get our cameras, you coward.
Get our cameras.
Get our cameras, Doki.
Doki.
Don't be scared.
Come on.
Oh, there's the other.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna be the hero.
And get our cameras, right?
As soon as I figure out how to get down from here.
Yeah, you got this.
She's not gonna do it.
I don't think so.
It's OK.
Oh, she's running away from it.
I'm gonna be the last one alive.
She's running away.
That's right.
It's your turn to watch me.
No!
I can't.
My picture of the headcrab.
He was launching at me.
Cool.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I got three more of these.
I'm doing it for you guys.
Wait for an explosion.
That would have been good.
That's good.
Alright.
It's so hard being me sometimes.
I did it.
It's so hard being me.
I did it, guys.
Yeah.
What happened?
We found out what the beholder does.
If he manages to get close enough to you when he spins, he explodes.
Yeah.
Oh!
It's actually pretty great.
Wait, did you guys all explode?
Yeah, we both exploded together.
But you died!
Our cameras don't work.
Our cameras!
Why did you get the cameras?
What a hero.
Don't worry, guys.
I got us the photos we needed.
Uh-huh.
Oh, wow.
Look at that.
277.
Oh, man.
We're making numbers.
Look at that.
Yeah.
And then...
I like the ads in the background.
I know.
It really adds to the dystopian levels.
They're all the same photo!
Turned fucking burst mode on and went AFK.
Yeah, but I got us 3000 points, though.
Don't worry, everybody.
We only need 500 points on the next one, I guess.
I think we'll get it.
No need to thank me, guys.
Unless we all die.
I'm just being a hero that we deserve.
My pro flashlight!
Hey, guys.
We still have our SD camera.
I will remember this, Doki.
I will remember this.
I don't care how many points my headcrab picture was.
It was cool!
I wanted to see it!
I had some cool photos, too, but I died.
We all died when we had some really cool photos.
You died to a car.
I don't want to hear it.
We are not the same.
Where should we go?
It was a very scary car.
We can go back into the same place.
Hold on.
Can it just happen at any time?
No, but...
You did something special.
I just ran straight into that car and nothing happened.
Her body...
Her skin is made of paper and her bones are made of glass.
Yeah, my bones are very fragile.
That was like a scary car, right there.
Okay, okay.
It's so pretty!
Look at this!
This is so awesome!
Wait, could we see the...
Could we see the guy spawn from inside here, I wonder?
I don't think so.
Can we just pull up in here?
Yeah, the siren basically says he spawns.
Suggie.
Everything makes me think of her.
I like this layout.
Yeah, I like it too.
Snow!
Which way do we go?
We have no flashlight, so...
We have to look through our camera.
I'm gonna follow Mint because clearly she knows what she's doing and hasn't died multiple times.
I go in for...
You know, I'm here for the scoop.
The thrill.
The scoop of it all.
It might be chocolate.
That's why she has a purple heart in journalism.
Purple heart in journalism.
It's not chocolate, it's not vanilla.
It's mint chocolate chip, baby.
That's the scoop.
Oh, we just went in a big circle.
Oh yeah, it was really good.
Great journalism, everybody.
Are we here?
I keep thinking that's an Enderman.
Oh wait, there's so much blood over here.
You hear the music?
Yeah, I do too.
I don't hear music.
It's like a...
Wait, there's body parts here.
I don't hear music.
Are you guys having a mass hallucination right now?
Where do you see body parts?
Listen to the coffee.
Did you just say listen to the coffee?
That's what this says here.
Oh my god, the pizza!
You're advancing madness or some shit.
Pizza, pizza!
Listen to the coffee, do you hear the music?
Alright.
Nothing here yet.
I can't wait to get you fucking nothing though.
Oh, there's a beholder in that room.
Do not let him get close.
That guy's a dick.
Go away.
He might start chasing after us though.
Wait, is that what he does?
He chases?
Yeah, he does come after you.
Oh god, I'm starting to go a little bit cuckoo.
Okay.
I think you can't stare at him.
I think that's actually it.
Oh, it's a CCTV room.
Nothing in here.
Nothing happens.
There's nothing.
There's no exit here.
I keep feeling like you can find loot in these places, but...
Oh, dead end.
Oh, we have to go out soon.
It's almost five minutes.
Oh.
What was that?
That's a mine.
Oh, I want to take a picture of the mine.
Yeah, you can take a picture of it.
But it's not a lot of points.
Oh, it's just 29.
Oh.
Okay, we should go now.
Yeah, let's go get the big guy.
The big guy shows up here.
Wait, how do we go back?
Is there really a point of going inside?
I wonder.
This area was very tame for a three-star.
Yeah.
Maybe everything is upstairs.
Maybe.
Oh no, it's a dead end.
Oh, seriously?
That sounds like something is spawning.
Oh, you can see explosions!
Oh no, you can't.
Let's go!
Let's get the big stuff!
Don't hear any fucking left.
I know.
Where's the spawn?
We should spawn up soon, right?
Yeah.
There's a big guy over here if you want a picture in the meantime.
Oh, there is.
He's prowling around the cars.
Where is he?
There's some dogs too, actually.
Oh, I can't get up there.
Oh, they're savaging some dudes.
Rest in peace.
Oh yeah, there's a big guy over there.
Where's the door?
Oh no.
Oh hey, you're alive.
What's up?
What happened?
What killed you?
It was the manhole thing.
It was over there.
Did you get some pictures, man?
No.
Well, I saw something fly.
I think I took a picture of something flying.
Zoki got eaten by a manhole.
Wait, did she die-die?
No.
Oh, ok.
Almost.
There's a guy right in front of me.
Oh, and there's another guy right here.
Wait!
We should leave.
I think it spawned right next to where the helicopter is, no?
I can run past it.
Oh, he's right next to the helicopter.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Um...
If we go around heavily to the left, I think he can't go that way and he'll go past us.
I'm gonna go right side.
Ok, I go right, you go left.
Ok, Zoki.
I'm following you.
I was.
How the hell?
Oh, there's an alien dog.
I can't get up!
Jump and hit control as you're at the top of your jump.
I did- Oh, there we go.
There you go.
Oh jeez, that almost hit me.
How do I leave?
Guys, how do I get out of here?
I'm being spawned- I'm being camp spawned by- Oh, this thing is so close to me.
Can you kill the dog?
Please?
Oh my god.
I lived!
Yeah, I got her camera.
Oh shoot!
She had more photos!
No!
I didn't realize she had a good one.
I lived!
I got some good photos.
You did not believe in the power of the right side.
That was scary.
You guys didn't believe in my right side.
Oh, look at me!
The guy fucking sniped me with a car.
Oh, look at my guy!
Oh, that's your guy.
I got hit by a car.
Yeah, you did.
I saw it happen.
What is that photo even?
What's even going on in this photo?
Oh my god.
I hate this game.
I don't want to play this game with you anymore!
I hate this fucking game!
Yeah, and everyone gets to see your fucking helmet that you have to wear.
Everybody gets to see Doki Bird with her stupid helmet.
I'm just really good at the news.
What can I say?
There you go.
Now we can all have helmets.
Blue camera is for everybody too.
Oh wow, I have one too.
Repeated photo.
Did you see they gave us something cool and new on the next difficulty level?
That's because... yeah, I see.
I think like every time we beat a level, we get to see a new monster.
Yeah, it seems to be the case.
Oh yeah, we are all special now.
We all have the special helmet.
Lime, you lost your hair.
Oh wait, we'll never get to see that funny photo of Lime.
Because Doki didn't get the camera because she's a coward, stupid baby.
The photo of you dancing in front of the thing.
Yeah!
Oh nice.
I'm scared of going near cars now.
The PTSD.
I hear music.
Cars and ladders.
Yeah, pretty much everything.
I mean, there's nothing in front of us.
This is a horrible map.
This is like a really difficult map to start people on.
Because like it's so far away.
There's a building actually right across here.
Oh yeah.
It's cool to go to that building.
I wanna go to Sarota Bank.
I feel like we should all stay outside and like camp somewhere and then get the big monster when he comes.
Cowards.
What?
It's for the money!
Call me in the hotel lobby.
This building looks cool.
I like it.
You wanna stay outside and not see this amazing place.
I mean, amazing is subjective.
Amazingly fucked up hotel.
That means there's vacancy, guys.
We can get a suite for a discount.
Oh my god, we can get a suite!
A suite discount, get it?
Okay, this just looks like an office now.
Oh yeah.
Now we're back in the studio.
How do you feel about that?
Oh, it's the pupil.
Pupil.
Where?
He's right there.
Oh yeah, I see him.
What is it doing?
I wish it's closer.
So I can get a better photo.
Oh.
Ew.
He's like a little tarantula.
I don't even see him.
He just went out of sight.
Oh, I see him.
Oh, he's gross.
He's like a little octopus.
Yeah, he's kinda cute.
Uh oh, he's going upstairs now.
Yeah, but he can't do anything.
He's just a...
You think that?
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, he's leaving.
Oh, he just walked away.
See, I told you he wouldn't do anything.
Going through our exit.
The way we needed to go.
I'm sure we won't have a problem when we need to leave.
Oh, there's like the skin masks here.
The stalagmites.
I feel like the building layouts in this game are a little bit better than Lethal Company.
And that if you go like more than 10 feet from the entrance, you don't get endlessly lost inside an infinite labyrinth and never get out again.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I think this leads back to the opening room.
Yeah, we just...
What?
I got a cool photo though.
Me too.
I got a 700 score photo because he was flying at my face.
Nice.
I got a 900 photo.
Me too, I got one too.
Let's go.
Oh.
That is a modified dog.
Can you pose for me?
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I like how the immediate pose is just like the fucking hands in the air.
Pose number 8, baby!
Never fail!
Oh, hello.
Can you pose for me?
Nice.
Oh, nice, nice.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Work it, baby, work it.
This was the way to do the shortcut, right?
It's not there anymore.
Wait.
There used to be a box there, I think.
Nope.
Still works.
Oh, he's here.
Oh, it's the military men.
I don't know.
Are they going to kill him?
I don't know if they actually can.
I don't think so.
I don't think they can.
I don't think so either.
Where are they?
I don't even see them.
They're in the bushes.
Oh, I see them.
Oh, damn, I missed it.
I got it.
There's a...
Big dude with a fist behind his...
Oh, shit!
It's the big man again.
Oh!
Is he going to slap me?
He's going to slap!
How can he slap?
Is he slapping?
Oh my god, what are you doing right now?
What are you doing?
You're the one on the screen.
Ok, I think we got the photos, right?
I still have seven.
I still have six left, yeah.
Oh, shit.
No!
We're good.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh, dang it.
I got it's ass though.
I have one more.
Ok, do something cool.
Oh!
Oh, wait, did she die?
Yes.
I don't know what...
Her helmet though!
She's got three photos.
Alright.
We made it.
It's fine.
A car flew over your head.
I know.
I got killed because I decided to take a selfie as a bus flew at me.
No!
Wait, did it show up?
Did that photo show up?
I hope so.
I wanna see.
I hope we get that photo of the bus.
Very nice.
I think that was the bus that flew at me.
Oh, yeah!
Very nice.
Damn, we almost got it in one.
Oh my god!
Yeah, we just need one more.
Wait, how many points do we need?
600.
600 points, yeah.
That's good.
I'm gonna download that.
And save to my desktop.
I like how we have two POV of this.
And we can watch everything.
Mine only counted more because you were in the picture too, I think.
Yeah, I was also in the photo.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
It's so cursed!
It looks like a...
Which one of us got hit?
I don't know.
Maybe it didn't go up before I fucking ate shit.
This one is so stupid.
Yeah, I like this one.
This one got the most points though.
Because it was a repeated photo.
This was the second photo you took.
If this was your first photo, you would have got more.
Yeah, I think so.
Dang.
I mean, that photo alone got you a thousand.
Hell yeah.
This game is easier, I think, than Lethal Company.
I feel like.
Much easier.
I mean, because we decide when to go.
We know when to go.
Oh, okay.
Apocalyptic.
That is so like...
What does that mean?
Explosions and monsters and corpses.
Yeah, but how is that worse than Darwin Awards?
Because you have to put yourself in danger for Darwin Awards.
Oh, do you want that flashlight?
Here you go.
I grabbed it for you.
Sorry, I couldn't get your helmet because I had...
Yeah, no, no, you're good.
I can probably do like one more.
Let's finish this, guys.
As long as someone gets out with like two photos, we win.
Yeah, we don't have to be super risky here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, we can find the...
Or risk it all.
Risk everything.
We're one day off of retirement, guys.
Oh, yeah, we're one day off of retirement.
Oh, and then we can like do...
If we pass this, we can do the later levels with Snuffy.
The final level.
Yeah, let's save progress, I think.
Oh, true, true.
Man, I sure can't wait to finish my job as a journalist and go spend the rest of my days with my family.
In and out, super safe.
There'll be no problems.
There'll never be a better thing than to go...
...retire in the Bahamas.
The Bahamas.
Do you want to go to this building over here this time?
Yeah, let's go to that building.
It's closer to the jump skip, too.
True.
Those growls are always...
They're always really close, but I don't think they're actually anywhere.
I call this the doki skip.
The doki skip.
Shortcut, I call it the doki skip.
The basic fucking crouch jump, Ari.
Aw man, we're in this building again.
Oh, there's a trap here?
Oh, and a stalker.
I invented it, though.
You invented crouch jumping?
That's crazy.
Alright, I'm gonna do the...
I'm gonna do the trap if anyone wants to...
...let me go.
Before you do...
Doki, take a pose in front.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing.
I'm dying, I'm dying.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, shoot.
I am.
And there's something coming after me!
I gamed, I gamed.
Holy shit!
Yeah, we did it, we did it, we did it.
I gamed, I gamed.
My favorite of the year right there.
Holy shit.
Watch out, watch out!
There's a guy right next to the shortcut.
Tiny man, tiny man.
What do we do?
Oh no, not the Doki skip.
He's guarding the Doki skip, what a dick.
If I die, you have to get my camera.
This is a very, very...
I got the apocalypse scenario in it.
I got apocalypse, yeah.
Okay, see if I can make this.
I did it last time, first try.
First try, I did it.
Alright,
it's time to go.
But what if we waited for the giant monster?
We could just wait up here, nothing gets us here.
I guess.
Or we just wait by the helicopter.
Yeah, that's true, we can wait by it and exit it when he shows up.
But one of us has to stay outside.
Not you, apparently.
Not me.
Okay, but if I die, get my camera.
Oh, there's a guy over there.
There he is, there's a little guy over there.
You heard that too, right?
He's coming over.
He won't get us.
We might have to leave if he doesn't stop walking towards us.
He's like hobbling over towards us.
Oh, he doesn't see you, he's blind.
He's nearsighted.
I know, stuff to our right, right?
I'm being Jurassic Park noises.
Oh, you're right, I hear that too.
That's spooky.
It's cause they're all around us, we're just...
Come on.
Hey, big guy.
There's no one behind us.
Oh my god.
It really is super Jurassic Park.
Oh, here it comes.
Camera's ready.
What the hell?
Oh, you're welcome.
I'll emote.
Once the guy comes in, you can use me.
You're welcome.
It's my pleasure to be your...
I'm ready for Slenderman.
I'm trying to find the best one that I can do.
Okay, I'll wave.
Number three.
Hello!
Oh, there he is!
It's the...
How lame.
Can you strike a pose for me?
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh wow, you're trying to maximize your min-maxing.
We already got it.
There we go.
I'm hoping that he explodes something, cause it'll probably give us extra points.
It is kind of right now.
Oh, there's a club there too.
He's coming.
The club.
I turned around.
I kind of want to see what happens if he gets sucked into the tornado.
Give this journalist a medal of bravery.
I know.
That's why I'm the only survivor.
We all survived.
What are you talking about?
Alright, let's see.
I'm pretty sure Lime got the best photo.
Yeah, Lime's award winning photo.
Yeah, the award winning photo right there.
Oh yeah, that one.
Mine was apparently just that much cooler.
I can't believe I...
Oh wow, I look awesome.
That was cool.
That one was cool.
Oh, I look awesome!
Lime's gonna be firing it though, so...
Better photo.
Yay!
We did it!
Alright, guys.
Look at my headliner here.
That is actually a really cool photo.
That is a really cool photo.
It's not a fucking cell that we burned once.
I know.
So our photos went...
Mid doing something real sus with a monster.
Actually cool photo.
Hey, and I'm in two of them, baby.
That actually looks like something I can see in a newspaper.
It actually has some form of composition going on.
Yeah, save it, save it.
Oh yeah, how do I save this shit?
I can submit this at the start of my journalism career.
Oh, here we go.
Rule of thirds, baby!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
We did it.
We learned how to be real journalists.
Yeah!
I can't wait to show Snuffy when she gets a new CPU.
I know.
We'll continue our run and get to level 5 with Snuffy.
Oh my god.
God, that's a trial by fucking fire.
It's like, hey Snuffy, go into this building and she just instantly gets monged by a headcrab or something.
You mean this isn't the best photo?
We all come back for one last time.
This isn't the best one.
Nobody likes this one.
Nice.
Oh yeah, there's you hanging.
Oh yeah.
Oh wow.
God damn.
YouTube don't look...
It does look pretty dark.
What is this photo?
This is such ass.
I'm not even in it.
You're like, hey, whoa, whoa.
You look like you're not a journalist.
You're actually going at the paparazzi after they found my...
They found my dangling body.
Oh,
this is where we did the explosions.
The fuck is that?
Oh, it's the guy that comes out.
It's the guy.
I saw him in there.
Me taking a selfie.
GG's guys.
It was a great pleasure being a journalist with all of you.
I think we were pretty good.
Yeah, I had a great time.
Look at that shit.
Let's take a selfie together.
One last selfie.
We should all do a selfie together.
Okay.
Oh, uh...
Wait, how does this work?
How do we get together?
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god, wait.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to A.
Oh, I'm trying to A too.
One last photo for the ride.
I love that you guys still have your safety helmets on.
Yeah, baby.
Yeah, we're special.
Oh yeah.
GG's everyone.
Thanks for playing Headliners.
It was fun.
Let's hope we can get Snuffy in next time.
Hell yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's hope...
Snuffy's PC will be okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna rest my voice right after this.
But GG's guys.
Let's hope Snuffy's PC will be okay.
I know.
Alright, bye bye.
Bye bye.
Bye.
See ya.
Yay,
that was so silly.
That was so fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed our silliness.
Our being silly journalists.
I feel like the game actually becomes a little bit like a strategy.
It's like, okay, how can I maximize my...
Everything.
Silly and deadly.
I can't believe Lime and I noclip through the world.
And then Doki exploded from a parked car.
Truly, I wonder...
I don't know.
Truly, we are the ones to do it.
Yeah, it was much easier than I Feel Lethal Company.
Because we were able to get much more.
We were able to see quite a few different maps inside.
So that was fun as well.
And I downloaded a lot of...
Wait, did it save my photos from...
Hold on.
Victory!
Thank you guys!
Sorry I couldn't read super chats or everything.
It was so much...
It's one of those games where you can't really look at chat much because I'm like, constantly like, where's the stalker?
Where's the headcrab?
Where's this?
Where's that?
The kaiju parts were actually super hyped thanks to the collab.
Yeah!
Thank you!
It was fun though.
It was fun, fun, fun.
Anyway, I'm hungry.
I'm gonna go eat some dinner.
So, um...
I hope you guys enjoy the rest of your day.
The rest of your night.
Happy Chocolate Minday Mindo!
Thanks for the silly, fun silly game.
Happy Chocolate Minday!
Burger.
Maybe that's what I'll have.
I don't know what to have yet.
Maybe a sandwich.
I don't know.
Otsumito!
Thank you guys!
See you later!
Bye bye!